bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale sur la visite du pape
françois qui se poursuit à edmonton au
lendemain de son arrivée dans la
capitale albertaine journée très
importante dans son séjour canadien
puisque c'est celle des excuses qui ne
doit refaire ou survivants et il va le
faire sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnats pour autochtones qui se
trouve au sud d'amman tonnes alors avec
moi je retrouve mes invités hier alain
crevier spécialiste des affaires
religieuses bonjour aline bonjour s'il
est de retour ces plaisirs isabelle
picard être no dogs huron wendat bonjour
rebonjour isabelle mergault
et marie-eve coton lé psychiatre qui
pratiquent régulièrement dans le grand
nord auprès des populations autochtones
merci madame coton marielle content
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
alors avant de m'entretenir commencé
avec vous je vais tout de suite aller
voir ce qui se passe sur le lieu où le
pape sera dans quelques minutes les
anciens élèves des pensionnats leur
famille peuvent accéder en tout temps
donc à 7 à cet endroit alors
bonjour il dit n'être
bon sur ce lien alors dites nous c'est
un moment important évidemment pour
beaucoup d'autochtones des métis et des
inuits qui sont arrivés très tôt ce
matin là pour assister sur place à ses
excuses
oui un moment très important et vous
savez geneviève il est important de
deezer aussi que ce sera une journée
difficile pour plusieurs survivants et
aussi une journée qui sera riche en
émotions vous savez en ce moment on se
retrouve un masque which is full avait
mentionné c'est au sud d'el menzah
environ une heure alors on s'attend à
voir des milliers de personnes environ
6000 personnes qui vont être réunis ici
sur sur le site là au sein de la
communauté je vous montre qu est ce qui
se passe immédiatement vous voyez
derrière moi sept tunnels
déjà il ya foule plusieurs survivants
c'est la place qu'on réserve aux
survivants et à leurs proches plus loin
à l'extérieur de la tonnelle il y a
plusieurs chaises ou le voyez en ce
moment c'est une place aussi qu'on
réserve à des survivants mais d'autres
personnes de différentes communautés à
travers le pays qui sont venus assister
à ce moment un moment très important
tout simplement dans un premier temps
parce que le pape va visiter le site
d'un ancien pensionnat un ancien
pensionnat pour autochtones élimine
skins et il va aussi faire son premier
discours public c'est à dire prendre la
parole où il devrait réitérer ses
excuses aux survivants nessuno parle de
beaucoup d'émotion parce que qu'est ce
que le pape va dire quels sont les mots
qui va utiliser le ton qui va choisir
mais aussi comment les gens et
survivants vont recevoir ses paroles à
peine avant d'entrer en ondes ont
discuté avec une survivante de la
colombie britannique
elle expliquait son témoignage qu'elle a
passé à travers on l'arraché de sa
famille comment elle a vécu cette
situation à travers les pensionnats mais
aussi le drame intergénérationnel je
l'écoutais est vraiment des frissons
tout simplement là de voir cette dame
avait accompagné de son frère et de son
petit fils et elle tout ce qu'elle veut
c'est qu'on reconnaisse la vérité
l'histoire de ce que les autochtones ont
vécu dans les pensionnats donc lens vous
entendez à un programme qui va commencer
avant l'arrivée du pape mais juste avant
je vais vous inviter à écouter deux
commentaires qu'on a pu recueillir pour
vaud va venir tout au long de la journée
avec d'autres commentaires des gens
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent aujourd'hui
comment ils se sentent est vraiment
c'est un moment qu'ils partagent et
qu'ils attendent de voir qu'est ce que
le pape aura alors ça voici de
commentaires que nous avons recueillies
qui cette maman
jeanine
alors woody net il y en a beaucoup de
gens qui sont venus des autres provinces
on n'est pas juste la région n'est pas
jules de l'alberta nécessairement pour
être pour assister à ses excuses
exactement ce levier viana qui viennent
de la colombie-britannique d'autres de
la saskatchewan ya différents transports
qui ont été mises en place des autobus
des autobus adapté parce que ce sont des
aînés aussi et je termine tout
simplement vous rappelant qu' il y à des
services de soutien psychologique qui
sont aussi en place on parle de
personnes avec des gilets bleus là
qu'ils sont prêts à écouter les
différences survivants donc une journée
qu'on parle difficile oui sur le plan
physique émotionnel et spirituel donc ce
qu'ils ont besoin d aide sur ces trois
plans là ils peuvent en obtenir sur
place lui aussi les premiers secours tri
qui sont à présent des collations des
boissons aussi qu'ils doivent être
distribués aux survivants et à d'autres
personnes ici alors voilà comment ça va
se dérouler on attend la venue du pape
au taux de 9 heures 45 10 heures heure
locale et dois je termine en rappelant
qu'il doit aussi visiter un cimetière et
visiter le style de l'ancien pensionnat
comme je vous le disais et une église
aussi ici à masquer which vous parler
des risques aux logiques aux gens
présents sur place là pour qui tout ça
va réveiller de douloureux souvenirs je
vous rappelle à ceux qui nous écoutent
aussi qu'il y a une ligne téléphonique
des deux psychologique dont le numéro
apparaît à l'écran je vous le donne
c'est le 1 8 6 9 2 5 4 4 1 9 merci
beaucoup usine est en outre en plus tard
au plaisir
alors revenons maintenant à nos invités
sur le plateau je commençais avec vous
marie-eve coque du canton
expliquez-nous pourquoi c'est si
éprouvant c'est un moment si éprouvant
pour les gens pour les survivants parce
que parfois on parle l'histoire qui
remonte il ya 20 30 40 ans ça fait
longtemps et pourtant ça peut être
encore très douloureux absolument parce
que l'intensité des traumas dans l'île
dans les pensionnats autochtones c'est
une intense d'autres mots extrêmement
élevé je vous dirais que si comme
puisque hier j'avais à penser à une
façon de faire mal à un enfant tous les
ingrédients s'y retrouve donc les couper
du jour au lendemain de leur figure
d'attachement de leurs figures de
sécurité
parents ou leurs grands parents et leurs
grands-parents cifonelli famille étendue
sont très impliqués en général donc dans
l'ue ce n'est pas le modèle la famille
nucléaire chez les autochtones ensuite
les mettre dans un environnement où ils
ne comprennent pas la langue et leur
interdire de porter leur de parler leur
propre l'homme dont qui sont dépourvus
de communication pendant un certain
nombre de mois ils vivent dans la
terreur et ça c'est sans compter les
abus qui sont survenus chez un grand
nombre et donc ça c'est des niveaux
traumatismes qu'ils prennent j'ai que la
guérison des survivants s'étale sur une
vie en général pour eux et elle s'étend
sur des générations en andorre dans leur
jeune âge donc c'est vraiment d'être au
moins important et là la distance des
années ne sera pas une protection contre
les réactivations traumatique
aujourd'hui d'autant plus isabelle qu'on
le suit pour beaucoup d'autochtones qui
sont passés par les pensionnats c'est
resté enfoui c'est resté caché et
certains parents n'ont pas dit à leurs
enfants qu'ils avaient vécu le
pensionnat et pourtant ça entache et
toutes leurs relations familiales
oui en fait c'est au début des années 90
qu'on a commencé à entendre parler des
premières histoires des premiers abus
des premiers trauma qui ont été vécues
dans les pensionnats mais avant ça
c'était plutôt rare ça a était tabou
pendant longtemps ça a été cachée et
effectivement ça a brisé le lien entre
les enfants et les parents pendant
longtemps et donc maintenant on en parle
mais c'est pas tout le monde qui est
rendu au moins au même endroit je pense
que marie-eve pourrait en témoigner de
par sa pratique il ya des gens qui en
parlent des anciens survivants qui en
parle qui sont plus ouverts avec avec
l'histoire avec leur histoire mais y en
a d'autres pour qui c'est encore très
douloureux et les prochaines journées
vont être extrêmement difficile pour les
survivants des pensionnats pour leurs
enfants aussi qu'ils ont dû vivre avec
sa part tout ce qu'on dit c'est ce sont
des des séquelles qui sont multi
générationnel oui parce que quand on
perd son ou sa mère a été pensionnaire
il a pas appris lui-même à être parent
alors c'est d'autant plus difficile pour
lui de l'être avec son fils est pour ça
qu on dit que c'est intergénérationnel
c'est simple en coton oui il ya plein de
façons ou le trauma va se répéter de
génération en génération mais c'est le
plus important c'est à dire que c'est
les gens qui sont allés au pensionnat
ils ont perdu contact avec le modèle
parental de leurs parents biologiques
ils ont été élevés s'ouvrir dans des
conditions coercive violente extrêmement
rigide et donc c'est ce qu'ils
connaissent comme modèle parental ils
deviennent aussi des parents traumatisés
qu'ils ont dû composer avec leurs
propres traumatismes en même temps
qu'ils vivaient là la tâche d'être
parent qui est très difficile et donc
quand on compose avec notre propre maxi
ça peut être de plein de façons ça peut
être parce qu'on a des permanents des
périodes de dépression des période
d'anxiété on peut ce tome et dicaments
thé avec des substances mieux toutes
sortes de façons il ya parfois aussi des
gens qui vont entrer dans ce qu'on
appelle une identification à l'agresseur
c'est à dire qu'ils vont eux-mêmes
développer des comportements agressifs
compte tenu de ce qu'ils ont vécu dans
le passé donc tout ça après ont été
vécus par leurs propres enfants c'est là
où il y eu des traumatismes comme ceux
qui sont le pas lent vêtu se perpétue
allez je vous ai dû prendre des notes
quand on wheels net nous parlait on sait
que l'attenté grande donc aujourd'hui de
ces paroles du pape et on attend de
l'authenticité est ce que le pape frank
vue prend des notes oui je vous ai bien
prendre les notes j'ai bien sûr assez
sale authenticité la façon dont il va
livrer ses excuses et très important
tout juste qu'il va dire non et c'est
exactement ce que je fais je pousse
aussi sur ce qu'on vient dire j'ai fait
plusieurs reportages des victimes de
prêter de file est la première chose le
plus gros drames qu'ils ont ce moment
donné de ce sentier de reconnaître ce
qui s'est passé de faire reconnaître ce
qui s'est passé et de comprendre qu'ils
sont utiles pour vous en sortir et c'est
une longue expérience des décennies il
en parle d'une nation de plusieurs
nations ac c'est gravissime et là
j'entends
le mot excuse le mot pardon c'est comme
s'il y avait des gens qui souhaitaient
que quand on dit je m'excuse et pardon
vient avec c'est comme ipso facto un
plus un égale mais voilà vous
vous entendez même certains évêques dire
ça c'est j'ai aussi un peu trop
traumatisant je dirais alors qu'elle
quels sont les mots qu'on dit ah qu'il
est dit on comment les dit on pour être
sincère et l'homme dans tout vous avez
un autre on attendait quelqu'un dire
j'espère que ma femme va vivre
l'expérience qui sera authentique et
qu'on pourra reconnaître que le véhicule
avait là les trois mots je pense sont
les mots clés est ce que le pape peut
trouver les mots justes qui va
satisfaire sa touche à tout le monde
j'ai un doute j'ai un doute
pourquoi parce que
écouter la panoplie de réaction qu'on
connaît maintenant ça va dans toutes les
directions il y en a que c'est
extrêmement grave c'est exotique traite
des coûts de façon très intense alors
c'est quoi la mettons mettons que le
pape dise de belles paroles et 10 nous
élisent on savait tout ça est ce qu'il
ya des gens parmi les nations qui diront
je le crois pas est ce qui se pourrait
que quelqu'un ce moment ci de l'histoire
sans quelques années après le début du
pass anneau 10 vous avez perdu toute
crédibilité à mes oreilles
est-ce que ça se passe c'est très très
potentiel il tenait en être seulement le
fait que la conférence des évêques
catholiques du canada a présenté des
excuses sans équivoque mais comme un des
excuses à 2021 max et ses tares d'un
processus alors je sais pas je pense que
la notion et même je tirais la notion de
ce qu'on appelle le pardon je me demande
si chez les premières nations c'est le
premier peuple la notion de pardon pas
une résonance tout à fait autre que
donne le système pénal où on trouve
quelqu'un on trouve coupable en prison
subite à peine peut-être que chez les
premières nations il ya quelque chose
qui est plus de l'ordre de retrouver
l'équilibré retrouver l'harmonie du
groupe et on n'est plus dans la même
logique on est proche de la justice
réparatrice son nid on est proche de
quelque chose d'autre est ce pour ça moi
avec mes oreilles la de journalistes
jean entendre les paroles du parrain
il faut que je fasse attention parce que
c'est pas moi que oui il va les recevoir
bien sûr alors je vous propose de
continuer pour parler parce que le pape
donc ce sera va même faire une prière
sur le site de cet ancien pensionnat
sous du cimetière aussi qui est adjacent
on sait que ce pensionnat d'autres en
tout cas certains sites d'anciens
pensionnaires vont faire l'objet de
fouilles pour trouver les sépultures
d'enfants autochtones comme celles
découvertes il ya un an à kamloops en
colombie britannique et dont les images
ont fait le tour du monde j'en parle
avec la directrice du programme en
études autochtones de l'université de
montréal elle est professeur titulaire
au département d'anthropologie marin
pierre bousquet bonjour madame
bonjour alors expliquez nous pourquoi
cette découverte à kamloops a été si
fondamental qu'est ce que cela nous a
appris sur les pensionnats
alors d'abord je voudrais commencer par
dire un mot je pense à tous à tous les
pensions les anciens pensionnaires que
je connais au québec et je voudrais
juste commencer par les saluer parce que
je pense à eux et à l est il ya beaucoup
qui sont en marche actuellement vers
guerre québec et donc voilà je vraiment
pour
cette découverte l'année dernière en
fait n'était pas une découverte pour
tout le monde mais ça a été une onde de
choc parce que je pense que les gens
réaliser concrètement qu'est ce que
c'est avec ce qu'a pu être l'histoire
des pensionnats
c'est à dire que beaucoup d'enfants ne
sont pas revenus chez eux quand on
envoie ses enfants dans une école on
n'imagine pas qu'ils vont y laisser leur
vie et il ya quand même
plusieurs milliers d'enfants qui sont
jamais rentrés auprès de leurs parents
parce qu'on sait dans le pensionnat
d'hermine skender muskin
près de là dans les années 20 près de la
moitié des pensionnaires qui ont eu la
tuberculose et beaucoup en sont mortes
parce que les conditions de vie dans ces
pensionnats
on peut dire que ce n'était pas très
très salubre là il y avait ça manque
d'hygiène c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire oui parce
qu'il ya eu donc un médecin le médecin
qui était responsable c'est arbitres de
santé publique qui est elle a fait toute
une tournée des pensionnats qui existait
dans l'ouest au tout début du 20e siècle
il a écrit un rapport c'était le docteur
peter bryce et ce rapport que vous
pouvez d'ailleurs télécharger sur
internet maintenant a été tabletté est
ce ce rapport il a même publié en 1922
après sa retraite pour que les gens en
prennent connaissance et l'a intitulé et
nationales 'crime crime nationale est ce
qu'il raconte dedans alors qu'ils
étaient pro pensionnat le docteur breiz
mais il raconte les conditions
sanitaires déplorables des pensionnats
et il disait que dans la plupart des
pensionnats il y avait au moins 30 % des
élèves qui mouraient d'épidémie est que
dans un des pensionnats qu'il a visités
jusqu'à 69 % des étudiants mouret de
généralement de la tuberculose et il a
il avait donné en fait dès l'époque
n'avait pas encore tous les vaccins dont
on dispose aujourd'hui mais il avait dit
au moins de séparer les élèves malades
je serai en bonne santé ce qui n'a pas
été fait c'était simple 1 et ce rapport
a été tabletté donc c'est là une forte
responsabilité a à la fois des clergés
et du gouvernement fédéral voilà
maintenant les pensionnats on a entendu
à travers certains témoignages dont
celui de revios saganash sierre qui me
disais bon qu'il apprend il est au
pensionnat il apprend son père est mort
et est le pensionnat ne veut pas payer
pour qu'il retourne dans sa communauté
enterrer son père et ça c'était
il ya plein d'exemples comme ça c'est
ponctionne ces pensionnats n'était pas
riche riche non plus ça c'est vrai
ces pensionnats manqué de ressources on
sait d'ailleurs que dans pas mal de
pensionnat les enfants avec froid ils
avaient faim il n'était pas assez
nourris ça c'est sans compter certains
pensionnat où il ya eu des expériences
nutritionnelle c'est à dire en gros on
priver les enfants de certains
nutriments pour voir comment il allait
réagir
mais il y avait un manque de ressources
certains donc non seulement déjà il
manquait de ressources mais en plus de
ça en plus les personnels qui peut dans
les pensionnats et n'est pas forcément
des congrégations qui étaient vouées à
l'éducation qu'ils savaient pas
forcément très bien non ni seulement ni
enseigner ni s'occuper d'enfants whip il
enseigne la recette pour le vélo et
l'enseignement qu'on les produits guêpe
rodriguez s'est souvent amusé comme un
journée c'était plutôt technique l'a
alors ça dépend des des écoles en fait
mais parce qu'il ya eu des écoles
industriels qui n'était pas du tout joué
à enseigner lire écrire compter et
d'autres où lens et d'enseignement a été
bien meilleur mais il y avait toujours
de toute façon d enseignement technique
par exemple puis avoir de la menuiserie
cours d'agriculture des cours de cuisine
tas de choses parce qu'on avait dans
l'idée que
l'on allait former en fait les
autochtones à faire des métiers de de
d'ouvriers ou devenir agriculteur donc
c'était moi j'en connais plusieurs qui
ont appris les bases de l'électricité
des choses comme ça dans les écoles
ouais
revenons maintenant à ces tombes qu'on
décrit comme anonyme je pense à celles
de kamloops donc découverte il ya un an
est ce que c'est possible à votre avis
monseigneur poissons de l'après de la
conférence des évêques catholiques musée
non c'est peu probable qu'on les
intéressant les rituels catholique
habituel
et pourtant il y en a là on sait qu'on a
des tombes anonymes parce que c'est
possible votre avis qu'on les a enterrés
sans autre forme de rituel vous que
aussi c'est le temps qui a effacé les
traces
franchement il ya que les ânes les
archives qui pourrait nous le dira moi
ça me paraît surprenant si ces enfants
avaient été enterrés sans rituel parce
que l'église catholique est une grosse
bureaucratie et il ya toujours des
rituels qui sont faits et normalement on
doit en tenir compte donc pour
d'ailleurs les chercheurs c'est assez
pratique pour ça parce qu'on a des
traces après n'importe quel baptême
naissance fin vous reste
mariages enterrements on a des traces
si qu'ils aient été enterrés sans
virtuel ça me surprendrait beaucoup
parce que c'est pas du tout une quelque
chose d'habituel dans l'église
catholique après ça moi je pourrais pas
vous répondre c'est vraiment les
archives pour et d'ailleurs ces archives
dans les fouilles en tant que telle
qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent nous
apprendre parce que elles sont
entreprises pas partout parce qu'à des
nations qui ne veulent pas entreprendre
ces fouilles mais il y en a déjà qui
sont commencés ou qui vont commencer
qu'est ce que ces fouilles peuvent nous
apprendre et ses archives dont vous
parlez et auquel les autochtones n'ont
pas encore tout à fait accès qu sont aux
mains de l'église pour ce qu on sait qu
est ce que ça pourra nous apprendre
alors tout dépend du type de fouille qui
va être entreprise pour l'instant les
fouilles qui ont été entreprises ont été
obligées au radar c'est à dire qu'on
passe un instrument au dessus de la
terre en creuse pas c'est une espèce de
ça ressemble à un socle de deux
poussettes pour bébés en fait et ça
permet quelque part d'un peut scanner
s'il ya en dessous et en général c'est
utilisé avant des fouilles avec les
pelles etc avant excavations pour savoir
quel est le
en fait qu'est-ce qu'il ya
potentiellement en dessous donc pour
l'instant ce sont des fouilles au
géoradar qui permettent d'avoir des
idées
qui donnerait vraiment des réponses
après c est ce qu on va jusqu'à exhumer
les corps ou pas ça c'est des décisions
extraits un moment difficile à prendre
pour des nations ça suscite des émotions
quand tout à fait compréhensible
d'ailleurs
vous ressortez son besoin de venir il
faut qu'il y ait des noms est bon c'est
les archives qui vont pouvoir aider à
savoir qui est là et êtes-vous persuadé
de l'existence de thèse archives des
renseignements précieux qu'elle
contiendrait
alors le souci c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu
de politique d'archivage
systématique et des pensionnats avant la
commission de vérité et réconciliation
et que beaucoup d'archivés en fait se
retrouver dans des congrégations et
congrégations site des archives privées
donc il faut d'abord que les archives a
été conservée et qu'elle ait été
conservé en bon état l on va peut être l
onf avoir subi des incendies de
l'humidité etc vous avez des
congrégations qui ont fermé parce qu'il
n'y a plus assez de personnel et on sait
pas du tout où sont les archives donc
c'est un travail de fourmi en fait et on
ne sait pas si on a toutes les archives
ou pas et où elles sont parce qu'il faut
aussi pouvoir les localiser d'abord et
ses archives permettrait peut-être de
faire le lien entre
ces dépouilles anonymes et les
pensionnaires
et l'identité alors dans une cercle dans
une certaine mesure oui mais à mon avis
pour connaître un petit peu les tod
certaines archives on n'aura jamais des
réponses à 100%
une dernière question madame bousquet
est ce que l'église en tant
qu'institution
doit s'excuser vous avez entendu les
excuses du pape à rome en croix qui va
réitérer sensiblement la même chose ici
est ce que est ce qu'il doit aller plus
loin s'excuser au nom de l'église
admettre qu'elle savait que ce que la
hiérarchie religieuse devait savoir ce
qui se passait dans les pensionnats
ce qui est très important c'est que le
pape répondent à l'appel à l'action qui
avait été lancée par la commission de
vérité réconciliation
c'est important pour les anciens
pensionnaires c'est vraiment pour eux
que ça doit se passer et il faut que 7,7
qui est véritablement une reconnaissance
officielle de l'église du mal qui a été
fait est que ce soit en terre canadienne
c'est pour ça qu'il est venu après ça ça
relève vraiment de je dirais delà de
la personnalité de du pape en question
mais est-ce que ça suffira pas de toute
façon ça ne peut être qu'un début
américain boussenac même qu'à vous ce
cas merci beaucoup d'avoir été des
autres de nous avoir éclairé sur ce
dossier merci
à la une réaction là dessus à ce que
madame bousquet nous disait des
pensionnats et la réaction de l'église
je trouve votre votre question sur
l'appel à l'action si je trouve que
c'est vraiment tout à fait ça savait il
ya on va voir dans quelques minutes la
tap qui va être reçue il sera présence
d'un ancien chef qui s'appelle willy on
l'appelle willy trop cher rietschel a
été aux passionnés ou où on s'envoie
leur ses 14 années de ces villes il
raconte que sa seule manière d'éviter
les agressions ça a été de findus pas
beaucoup de parts bravo le droit de
faire du parfum des cas des bonnes notes
n'étaient pas bons il cache en tout
sourdine matin quatre appuis étudié avec
sa lampe de poche par de bons acteurs du
sport de devenir professionnel de hockey
s'est cassé une jambe en faisant du ski
devenu un avocat ni devenu un mythe et
internationales dans le droit d une
jeune et il est aussi le commissaire un
des trois comme ça la commission vérité
réconciliation et john wood littoral
c'est lui que l'idée de la de l'appel à
l'action 58 - qui consistait à dire au
pape venez vous excuser sur notre
territoire et vous allez voir ces images
là tantôt en direct en le pape doit
savoir à qui va s'adresser et lui sait
très bien que ce qui se passe et si vous
avez là un de ceux qui étaient à rome le
1er avril dernier quand le pape fin des
premières excuses il en est sorti en
pleurant arizant qui ne s'attendait pas
à autant ça
il tout le reste c'était ça dépend des
individus des nations delà de la
souffrance de trouva que chacun
habitudes cela dit on a entendu
monseigneur poissons dont le pape
s'excuse ou 6 mai l'impression qu'on a
toujours et je m'adresse à vous et
isabelle sait que c'est le fait de
quelques pommes pourries d'une certaine
façon est ce qu'il est clair avec vous
ives avoue isabelle picard que l'église
pouvait pas ne pas savoir ce qui se
passait dans tant de pensionnat c'est
une grande question effectivement mais
il ya eu tellement
d'agression on commence à faire affaire
juste c'est juste la pointe de l'iceberg
lorsqu'on est en train de voir donc pour
moi c'est difficile de voir que vous de
comprendre que l'église ne savais pas
que les différentes strates de l'église
n'était pas au point
vous savez qu'on parle d' excuse pour
moi ça va être très important dans
plusieurs langues autochtones avant le
colonialiste il n'y avait pas de mot en
langue autochtone pour dire je m'excuse
on s'excuse est pas ont réparé et pour
moi c'est sort que le peuple doit
transmettre un peu à travers la demande
de pardon qu'il va faire à travers les
excuses doit y avoir de la sincérité ça
doit être fait de façon très simple de
façon très sentie sinon on va passer à
côté de quelque chose et quand j'entends
monsieur poisson hier qu'ils racontaient
que c'était l'effet de quelques pommes
pourries si chacun comme comme membres
des premières nations parce que c'est
tout le système qui pour moi était
coupable en fait qui est coupable de ce
qui s'est passé à l'intérieur des
pensionnaires et on doit le comprendre
si on veut réellement s'excuser de la
bonne façon oui
madame coton en tant que psychiatre six
survivants aujourd'hui quand ils vont
entendre ses excuses
[Musique]
comment est ce qu'on les prend comment
est-ce que s comment est-ce que des
excuses peuvent nous amener à guérir
j'imagine que c'est d'abord avoir comme
un miroir qui me dit oui je sais que tu
as souffert là je reconnais tu as france
absolument c'est l'élément le plus
important dans des expulsés la
légitimisation
et là la validation de la france de
reconnaître que eu agression qui a eu
abus et donc la souffrance par le fait
même est vu et entendu
est accueilli et je dirais que ça ça un
potentiel de faire du bien mais c'est
très complexe donc ça se peut que des
gens se sentent dans les survivants que
sam capable de recevoir ses excuses à ce
moment là il y en ad'autres ça pourrait
susciter de la colère ou ça pourrait de
dire ce n'est pas assez ou et mais quand
on s'excuse le pardon ça ne s'impose pas
et dans la façon de phrase et je trouve
que c'est important de dire voici on
reconnaît on s'excuse mais qui est
quelque chose qu'il laisse qui laisse la
liberté aux gens après ceux de pardonner
ou pas on ne doit le pardon à personne
les survivants ne doive le pardon à
l'église ils vont peut-être la corde et
certains d'entre eux intérieurement
d'autres peut-être plus tard pas
maintenant d'autres jamais parce que ils
vont garder une indignation en eux qui
est pas nécessairement destructrice qui
peut être un moteur pour faire valoir
les droits des gens tu es le pardon
c'est ça peut être une voie de guérison
les salles et pour beaucoup de gens
pour d'autres personnes la guérison va
passer par un autre chemin mais qui est
pas plus mal ça non plus mais est ce que
le fait que le pape vienne ici même si
on le reçoit avec colère est ce que les
mots qu'il va prononcer aujourd'hui même
s'ils sont accueillies par certains
comme preuve suffisants peuvent quand
même faire leur chemin avec le temps
absolument parce qu'il ya quelque chose
de très puissant dans la validation de
la douleur sa veillée canton les gens
nous disent comment on on accueille
comment se comporte avec quelqu'un qui
souffre on leur dit souvent tombé pas
tout de suite dans un mode
d'encouragement ou de tuer les deux ou
deux ça valait bien bientôt vous allez
voir c'est de vraiment dire ok je vois
l'ampleur de la souffrance je prends
acte je m'excuse sans mettre de pression
pour que vous devriez aller mieux le
c'est roland vraiment de laisser les
personnes libres s'exprimer libre vive
et après se laisser le chemin que frau
ces paroles là l'intérieur d'eux il y en
a que ça va prendre des mois des années
à ce que ça soit réintégrée dans le sens
qu'ils veulent donner à leur traumatisme
des fois y'a pas de solution à sal il ya
des fois il ya des perdants qui sont qui
sont faits je vous donne un exemple deux
personnes nathalie provost polytechnique
et madame de souza
deux de très rapidement après les
événements le poly nathalie dit j'ai
pensé oh pardon m'a dit très rapidement
madame de souza a perdu sa fille
anastasia qui l'a assassiné c'est la
seule qui est décédé au moment de das
jumaa dépit pardon vous arrive de voir
la réaction et puis dernier tient
absolument jamais et je me dis qu'ils
aient plus fin il y en eut trinh duc est
plus fait peu de doute jacques bigot je
me situerais moi si ça devait m'arriver
serait de souza l'exprimerai papa m'a
beaucoup de ce que je ressens excuse
pour moi c'est une cure parlement pas on
dit souvent que le pardon canton on est
bien accompagné quand la démarche et et
bien fait des fois c'est la personne qui
se tirent le mieux de ça ce sont les
victimes c'est peut-être un chemin pour
sortir de leur état dû stimulation mais
ça ne s'impose non non bien sûr que non
puis on le sait isabelle que parmi les
autochtones ccc très divers comme
attentes face à ses excuses et kom kom
kom kom relation ou si l église
catholique là on conseillait de la
colère ou six qui s'exprime dans la
colère de la colère ou 6 face à cet
événement à ce gros show diraient
certains s'en viennent oui effectivement
il ya plusieurs écoles de pensée il y en
a pour qui c'est important d'entendre le
pape en sol canadien
devant eux dire on reconnaît on s'excuse
on demande pardon plusieurs la plupart
veulent que ce soit en fait que les
actions soient au delà des simples
excuses donc par exemple donner l'accès
aux jeunes aux archives
enlever tout ce qui est la doctrine de
la découverte par exemple contribué de
façon responsable par défend donc on en
a parlé du coup hier le fameux 25
millions qui a pas finalement été donné
aux survivants des pensionnats donc de
différentes façons pour des survivants
c'est important pour d'autres ils
veulent carrément rien savoir la porte
elle est fermée et pour eux c'est
correct c'est un moyen de survie c'est
un moyen peut-être de guérison ne pas
juger ça donc il ya différentes façons
de voir la venue du pape ici au canada
parmi les premières nations et les
survivants alors maintenant parlons du
pape allons voir quelqu'un qui le suivi
depuis rome il ya quelques 80
journalistes qui étaient accrédités par
le vatican pour voyager dans l'avion qui
transportait le tapis qui sont donc
aujourd'hui de ce passage qu'il va faire
sur le site de l'ancien pensionnat de
munchkin permis le doublement de
senneville correspondant pour le
quotidien la croix monsieur démons de
senneville bonjour
alors on a vu un pape hier on l'a aperçu
brièvement dans la viande boîte et un
peu mais quand même se tenir debout il
est venu
et vous voir les journalistes avec sa
canne est ce que vous l'avez vu ce matin
comment va-t-il il ya décalage horaire
puis l'est plus tout jeune à 85 ans
alors on ne l'a pas vu ce matin en fait
y'a pas de l'image ce qui est sûr c'est
que il est parti de denton il est en
route vers fermes aquatiques nous très
concrètement on ne loge pas dans le même
endroit que le table donc on l'attend on
est en ce moment à notre coach il est
donc on attend qu'il arrive mais on n'a
pas de nouvelles de lui ce matin si ce
n'est qu'il est en route cela dit si
vous n'avez pas vu on sait toutefois que
c'est une journée très importante à ce
que est ce qu on sent de la fébrilité
dans l'entourage se passer et contacts
avec son entourage ce matin
nowitzki turquie une confiance que c'est
une journée très importante d'abord fait
deux premiers discours la première fois
que le pape a exprimé depuis son arrivée
en paire canadienne hier et voilà c'est
un moment important parce qu'on est à
cet endroit là parce que
les mots qui sont attendus sont des
paroles de m'excuser de demander pardon
donc oui évidemment il ya je ne sais pas
s'il ya de la taille ridicule mais en
tout cas il ya la conscience que c'est
un moment important que fait un moment
qui va marquer en fait la suite du
voyage
maintenant ils veulent entrer les
premières paroles publiques du parc même
si effectivement il ya eu une rcp
rencontre qui était davantage des
rencontres privées au cours desquelles
aucune parole au moins public noté paix
et change à votre connaissance à ce que
c'est le seul endroit
sa mascotte est le seul endroit où le
pape va formuler des excuses pour les
personnages
alors il est probable mangez pas j'ai
pas les discours à l'avant qu'il est
probable que
il formule des excuses d'aujourd'hui et
après la question se trata voir et ce
qui va s'excuser demandé pardon à chaque
fois qu'il s'exprimait au cours de ce
voyage ou est ce que au contraire au
contraire plutôt est ce qu'il va y avoir
une forme de de gradation c'est à dire
qu'il va apparaître dans le porno gay
des excuses aujourd'hui et après évolué
voire d'autres thèmes dans les jours qui
viennent mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
le pape françois je commençais par
formuler à nouveau de cette exclu sans
doute de manière d'ailleurs plus forte
parce que tous savent les fêtes de fin
mars-début avril à rome lorsqu'il avait
reçu des délégations d'autochtones
pendant plusieurs heures au vatican
qu'est ce qui selon vous serait plus
fort encore que ce qu'il a utilisée
comme moi on
sait alors il ya des mots il ya des
gestes d'abord il peut y avoir des mots
de reconnaissance du rôle
non seulement passager mais aussi
systémique de l'église catholique dans
le système des pensionnats mais aussi
dans la mentalité colonisatrice
coloniale qui sont qui est qui est
arrivé a
fait renaître ces pensionnats c'est la
première chose et puis après il ya
évidemment toute une série de gestes
qu'ils sont vous savez beaucoup mieux
que moi 13 datant d'une fille par
rapport aux archives par rapport aussi
aux objets qui sont
actuellement dans les musées du vatican
donc voilà il ya à la fois des mots est
à la fois à des gestes qui pourraient
intervenir au cours de ce voyage en car
on sent bien qu'ils sont très attendus
donc aujourd'hui ce premier contact ses
premiers mots en sol canadien face à des
autochtones et quelques 6000 personnes
vasquaal chiche
c'est ça passe ou ça casse ça donne le
temps en tout cas pour le reste du
voyage
mis ça va donner le ton pour le reste du
voyage et le ton était au dessus de lui
hier lorsqu'il est arrivé moi ça m'a
beaucoup marqué lorsque cette cérémonie
d'accueil très sobre qui a été organisée
à l'aéroport de moncton dans un hangar
en silence sans mot public et changer
sans prise de parole ce moment en fête a
donné le ton du voyage c'est à dire la
gravité l'a dit et aussi voilà un pape
qui vient vraiment pour présenter ses
excuses et qui vient vraiment demander
pardon et je pense que ceci
d'ancillaires que nous avons vu à
edmonton entendu presque attendu et un
silence bruyant mais un silence qui
était plaint du drame des survivants et
auquel vient aujourd'hui faire passer
est que confronté ce pape venu de nulle
d'europe oui maman de senneville merci
beaucoup au revoir merci à vous
et bien allons-y sur place où se trouve
will dean est alors le pape est attendu
bientôt est ce que est ce que la foule
se densifie vilaine
voit exactement geneviève ici on voit
les gens continuent à arriver je dirais
que c'est surtout la home eu lieu à
l'intérieur du tunnel que c'est plein on
s'attend ce justement l intérieur c
environ 2000 personnes qui peuvent être
à 6 actuellement à l'intérieur ce sont
surtout des survivants accompagnés de
leurs proches et bien sûr tous attendent
la venue du pape tous attendent de voir
qu'est ce qu'il aurait dit à l'extérieur
maintenant on parle d'environ 4000
personnes également des survivants qui
seront assis ici écouter aujourd'hui on
a vu la pluie moins de pluie à certains
moments là ça commence à se dégager ce
qui va aider parce qu'il ya plusieurs
personnes des aînés qui sont sur place
pour cet évènement de la journée alors
revenons au justement sur cette journée
qui est importante cruciale pour
plusieurs survivants pour plusieurs
peuples autochtones c'est un faux parce
qu'au coeur de cette journée il y a deux
sources conservait tout particulièrement
la visite du pape sur le site d'un
ancien pensionnat celui de hermine skin
mais aussi le discours du pape tantôt
l'intervenant parlait du thon la
dernière lorsque le pape est venu à
l'aéroport de moncton n'y a pas eu de
discours officiel on savait que ses
premières paroles halle est réservé aux
peuples autochtones ont sa tasse qui
réitère ses excuses
maintenant pour plusieurs qu'est ce que
le pape bazar ça ressemble et ses mots
on veut aussi savoir le temps quel sera
le taux qui va utiliser plusieurs visent
aujourd'hui on veut une authenticité on
veut que ce soit véritable et finalement
comment les gens vont recevoir écouté
depuis qu'on est arrivé en temps de
parler à différentes personnes parfois
des survivants parfois des membres de la
famille d'autres fois ce sont tout
simplement des gens de la communauté qui
explique à quel point ce qui s'est passé
dans l'histoire canadienne ayew est née
vague n'est pas qu'haïti n'est pas cela
c'est à dire on retrouve des
traumatismes intergénérationnel aussi ou
encore il ya une intervenante qui
parlait de l'impact avec les femmes et
pise autochtones disparues et
assassinées dont tout cela ce sont des
éléments avec lesquels plusieurs
personnes arrivent ici à masquer which
is alors c'est une journée oui émotive
une journée qui fait revivre la qui fait
remonter des traumatismes alors bien sûr
on veut voir qu'est ce que le pape
aurait dit dans ce discours je vous
invite à écouter une intervenante qui a
bien voulu nous partager son histoire
vous avez ce que c'est une histoire qui
est difficile elle a expliqué qu'elle a
été dans un pensionnat pour autonomiser
à l'oreille qu'on n'a pas l'extrait on
va pouvoir vous le présentez un peu plus
tard mais elle nous disait on l'a
finalement mais on nous disait à quel
point ça a été difficile pour elle est
là et il dans un pensionnat pour
autochtone au moment de lorsqu'elle
devait partir elle ne voulait pas partir
ces sacrements qui lui a dit il faut que
tu ailles sinon je finis en prison et
finalement elle a été impressionnant et
tout simplement pour voir à quel point
ça a été épouvantable s'est passé alors
pour elle elle voulait présente elle
veut entendre de ses oreilles qu'est ce
que le pape aura à dire aujourd'hui je
vous invite à écouter une partie de
cette entrevue
en
face à
faire
merci beaucoup il tenait à moi vous dit
quelque chose ouais non j'allais tout
simplement ajouté geneviève parce que
c'est important de le faire tant donné
de l'ampleur de la situation le
traumatisme qui qui qui remonte comme je
le disais qu'il y à aussi du soutien
psychologique
aujourd'hui sur place pour les
survivants les aînés donc on parle de
soutien sur le plan physique émotionnel
mais également spirituelle dont beaucoup
de personnes ici est vraiment on
pourrait faire un tour dit chaque
personne a une histoire à partager alors
vraiment on est on est sur place à damas
immature et l'arrivée du pape au tour de
9h45 très très bientôt dans moins de
trois minutes merci beaucoup il dit
n'être on compte sur vous vous êtes nos
yeux et nos oreilles sur place juste
commenté un petit peu les images parce
qu'on voit on se rend compte un peu du
site je vous rappelle que c'est le site
de l'ancien pensionnat dermscan ktm un
des plus grands pensionnats pour
autochtones au pays qui étaient ouverts
de 1895 à 1975 rendez vous compte et ce
pensionnat il y avait des autochtones
nombreux la dent bien sûr qu'ils
venaient de quelques 10 huit communautés
autochtones différentes alors les
autochtones qu'on voit aujourd'hui on a
vu des chefs dans leurs costumes
d'apparat
représente donc toutes ces nations qui
ont été touchées par ce drame du
pensionnat der mesquine
alors ces gens donc qui attendent je
vous le rappelle l'arrivée du pape dans
quelques temps je vais revenir aux gens
qui sont avec moi on parlait beaucoup
d'authenticité un marie-eve coton de
l'authenticité des paroles du pape sy
quoi être attentifs quant à ce qu'on
ressent de tente ici de quelqu'un c'est
quand la personne qui parle prend la
pleine responsabilité de la faute quand
les gens sentent que la personne parle
pour le biais et la validation de l'eau
et non pas pour faire un exercice de de
relations publiques ou de redorer son
image que vraiment une sympathique et
exprime une compassion qui est exprimée
et où le discours est centré sur l'autre
igloo on ne glisse pas de minimisation
par ci ou par là par exemple s'il y
avait une insinuation qui est ce texte
qui avait pas un problème systémique
mais qui avait quelques individus qui
ont dérapé ce serait une façon de
minimiser de pas prendre la pleine
responsabilité de de la terme de la
violence qui ont été infligées dans le
camp yoyo une pleine reconnaissance et
qu'il ya un souci de l'autre qu'ils
ressentent si ces sauts de la sincérité
de l'hôte et donc le choix des mots et
ressasse pas juste 7 stud c'est pas
juste baisé la main aux survivants c'est
dans le choix des mots oui dans le choix
des mots et si je sais pas s'il va avoir
des survivants qui vont témoigner dans
la façon de recevoir ces témoignages le
aussi est dans la façon d'exprimer de la
sympathie après un souci je m'excuse de
vous interrompre en voit les images en
ce moment de tipi qui ont été érigées
sur le site de l'ancien pensionnat et ça
c'est le cimetière qui était adjacent où
au pensionnat dermscan on voit le
cortège papal
les motos justement qui arrive on va
tout de suite parlé à notre spécialiste
en sécurité marc 16 sava ex directeur
général adjoint de la sûreté du québec
bonjour monsieur savard
bonjour alors aidez nous à comprendre un
petit peu les images ce qu'on voit en ce
moment on voit des des gendarmes des
policiers en moto
je ne sais pas si c'était la police
provinciale ou si c'était la grc
hikma normalement on a déjà désigné
d'avant ce qui aurait la responsabilité
de l'escort pendant le trajet ce sont
des motos qui en général dans une grande
municipalité où il ya beaucoup
d'interceptions c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup de mots de trop bons être
technique on appelle ça excuse et
l'anglicisme et en boule gagne c'est que
ces gens-là vont vraiment s'occuper de
barrez chaque intersection contenu que
c'est vraiment un trajet où il n'y a peu
d'intersection les motos sont quand même
là au cas où et eux font vraiment ce qu
on appelle l avance du cortège et ce
dernier poursuive savez il ya tout un
défi actuellement c'est comment on fait
pour assurer la circulation sur cette
route en plein montage et masques huaxi
donc comment on fait pour assurer cette
sécurité est ce qu'on décide de bloquer
complètement le trafic et pour permettre
au pape
de d'arrivée sécuritaire mais il ya
toute une logistique fine pour ne pas
prendre toute la place mais d'assurer la
sécurité dans les images qu'on voit oui
je n'ai pas vu vraiment beaucoup de
poils ici n'ont effectivement une raison
non sens on peut on ne les voit pas
beaucoup cependant ils sont là je suis
convaincu ils sont probablement certains
en civil qui sont discrets le plus
possible mais il faut s'imaginer en
arrière-scène ci avait débordements on
voit le cortège je crois qu'il aime qui
arrive actuellement oui enfin
mon coeur est quoi l affaire
donc oui
la fiat 11,6 il pas alors voilà là tout
à fait tout à fait et on voit donc les
véhicules des scores nuls savez dans ce
genre
il ya évidemment les gens qui sont en
protection rapprochée et les véhicules
qui sont plus à l'arrière qui sont des
véhicules des groove et us qu'on voit ce
sont des gens qui ont une capacité
d'intervenir à l'intérieur de ça il ya
probablement même les médecins
personnels ou quelqu'un qui est capable
de s'occuper de la santé du tapis qui
avait une problématique des gens qui
sont capables d'intervenir et on a aussi
certainement dans la l'intérieur de ces
véhicules des gens qui bloquent la
transmission
donc ça me fait drôle un peu de parler
tout ça dans ces circonstances mais
c'est ce qui se passe en arrière scène
c'est quand on bloque la transmission
donc pour éviter l'utilisation
d'objets d'aitana est justement de se
servir des ombres donc on a une capacité
de bloquer tout le long du trajet cette
transmission donc qui pourrait être
néfaste vous pourrait provoquer un
attentat évidemment les gens sont sont
leurs sont contents de pleurs et ils ont
un objectif en étant sur les lieux mais
les autorités policières ne peut pas
prendre la chance de compter que sur la
bonne volonté mais la réputation du pays
est en jeu quand même tout à fait
écouter on voudrait certainement pas au
canada à le pays qui dans le futur bon
être un souvenir comme étant un pays qui
a permis à quelconque accident
volontaire
est ce que je comprends moi est ce que
je comprends aussi monsieur savard c'est
que donc la police doit être présente
mais s'étonne délicat exercice
diplomatique faut pas non plus trop
s'explique entre autre os montrer parce
que tombe bien les autochtones
les autorités policières représente une
autorité au crime hante longtemps
bah oui tout à fait dans le contexte
dans lequel nous sommes actuellement on
sait très bien qu'il ya une histoire en
arrière de des gens qui forçaient des
autochtones il y avait il y avait des
autorités policières ccc connu et il ya
toutes sortes d'événements auxquels on
peut se rappeler mais vous savez déjà
nous on n'est pas en train de discuter
de ce qui se passe à masquer au 6 mai
déjà là en amont il ya déjà toute une
logistique qui est en train de se
préparer pour ce qui va se passer en fin
de journée à à l'église et il ya encore
une logistique très différente de celle
qu'on voit aujourd'hui qui est entré de
se mettre en place et qui est en partie
déjà en place à edmonton au stade pour
demain matin tout à fait donc on peut
pas présumer que les gens ne sont sont
inactifs parce qu'on ne les voit pas ils
sont là il ya des capacités
d'intervention sur les lieux et je
trouve très intéressant dans la façon
dont on réussit vous savez les gens qui
planifient ceux qui sont dans la
gouvernance de m cette sécurité auront
des réunions et des rencontres
stratégiques avec les orques elle n'a
pas mais aussi entre deux autres pour
être capable justement de dire ok ou
mettons nos forces pour être capable de
répondre aussi un débordement pour qu'il
le soit qu'elles ne soient pas visibles
ils sont là je lui confirme qu'elles
sont la meilleure on fait attention
merci beaucoup merci monsieur savard
allez y vous avez levé la main vous
aider oui ce post on parle de ça comme
si c'était quelque chose de complètement
futile et théâtrale faut donc une
banquière de la sécurité des choses
qu'on s'appuie ce pape en particulier
qui est capable jeudi d'ouvrir la porte
à sortir il le fait mais c'est pas c'est
pas un spa un concept jean paul ii s'est
fait tirer dessus à bout portant et on
s'y attendait pas personne ne
s'attendait à vendre depuis l'attentât
de 80 1 il ya eu toutes sortes de
mesures qui ont été prises au vatican
des portes en métal des fouilles
d'essayer dé ça ce qui n'est pas
habituel pour les parcs n'apprécie pas
tamas ce genre de chose juste elle
souligné parce que on voit bien qu'ils
sont discrets tout seul mais pensez vous
qu'ils portent une veste pare-balles
lui l'a déjà dit ce serait la meilleure
manière de partie si ce qui est que lui
tirer dessus il ya rien qui le fais pas
dit si ça ne dérange pas mais en même
temps
c'est pas je pense que le canada s'est
totalement seulement son image qui tente
de protéger s'il ya c'est un leader
charismatique c'est un leader de foule
de gens et ils dérangent ils dérangent à
l'intérieur même de son église et
dérangent à l'extérieur là non c'est pas
parfaitement futile ces questions de
sécurité mais ça ne voudrait pas est un
agent de sécurité autour de l'union non
parce que je sais la difficile à
contrôler une certaine façon on me dit
comment on peut entendre le témoignage
de quelqu'un qui est sur place sur hamas
quoi site qui témoigne de ses attentes
face à ces excuses du patron l'écoutent
vincent
incroyable dans l'esprit et de tous qui
sont ici pour écouter le pardon de
demander le pardon du pata françois
alors je me sens que
mon coeur bat très fort pour écouter
écouter le pape directement parce que je
suis
je m'excuse je suis survivants d'un abus
sexuel d'un prêtre à l'âge de 7 ans
l'église catholique à winnipeg alors
pour écouter le pape demande et pour le
pardonner l'église catholique pour à les
abus pour moi c'est le premier ter pour
consultations aussi si nous donne
l'occasion pour pardonner à l'église
pour les abus
dans ma ma vie comme jeune j'étais très
fâché de
soi et victimes de ces abus
il s'appelait beaucoup de douvres âge
personnel pour asseoir et les tables de
pardonner et de avancé
ma relation avec l'église catholique
mon âme est prêt j'ai fait des prières
pour là pour recevoir le pardon du cas
d'important dans les mots exacts
prononcés oui
j'écoute est très fort a les mots je
reconnais que le pape ne soit pas
seulement l'espagnol et je vais écouter
ses paroles je vous écoute et la
traduction en anglais à des ces paroles
pourra reconnaître sa demande à
pardonner l'église alors pour moi c'est
une étable de reconsidération jeunes
étapes pour pur le meilleur esprit pour
moi il voulait pour matane et
comment penser que toulon n'a pas pu
voyager j'imagine dans votre communauté
comment vous pensez que
ça va être accueilli je reconnais
plusieurs survivants sont pas l'étape de
accepté
le pardon mais je crois que
c'est un pas très important pour
reconnais que le pab le plus beau dans
l'église catholique reconnaît les abus
pour moi c'est les gens faut reconnaître
que ce qui s'est passé au passé
il faut jamais oublier mais faut faire
la meilleure étape pour le futur pour
nos enfants et nos futures générations
car c'est bien notre foi catholique
alors pour moi c'est très heureux que le
pape
reconnaît lé la réalité et la réalité de
nos abus
alors non je viens d'entendre survivants
dont s'exprimer exprimé ses attentes
face aux excuses que le pape s'apprête à
faire des propos recueillis par notre
collègue sur le terrain où il dînait de
paul je vais tout vous m'adresser à vous
madame coton on voit qu'à comme des
étapes ou si un îlot dit carrément il
avait franchi une étape lui qu'il était
prêt à pardonner en entendant ses
excuses et des étapes sont pas
nécessairement au même rythme pour tout
le monde absolument c'est récepteur
jeunes dans les communautés d'abord le
rapport à la religion est hétérogène le
chemin de guérison était hétérogène
aussi vous être très différent d'une
personne à l'autre
alors on peut tout à fait s'attendent à
ce qu'il ya des gens actuellement qui se
sent dans un esprit de pardon dans l'ue
dont les survivants et d'autres non mais
qui vont quand même venir prendre acte
de ce message là qui vont seulement à
voir
où ça va continuer de se déposer en
nuées de 2,2 de s'insérer dans un chemin
des de guérison et alice sur plus
longtemps oui
isabelle je me faisais la remarque en
regardant les images qui nous viennent
de masse quoi s'il me demandait est ce
que tous ces gens qui sont là sont
forcément des croyants forcément
catholique ou si il y à parmi eux des
gens qui ont une spiritualité uniquement
autochtone mais qui ont besoin quand
même d'entendre ses excuses plus est
absolument au niveau de la spiritualité
dans les communautés c'est aussi très
hétérogène il ya des survivants ont le
vieillard qui sont encore de faire 20
catholique pour plusieurs raisons qui
font une différence entre la religion
catholique et l'église avec les hommes
de l'église donc ça il ya déjà ça mais
il ya pour plusieurs survivants aussi
que la guérison s'est faite à travers la
re découverte de l'art spiritualité
traditionnelle et donc on voit des gens
ici dans les images sont les images qui
sont habillés avec leur régulière
traditionnel leurs coiffes
traditionnelles faut faire attention ce
ne sont pas des costumes puisque ce sont
des habits traditionnels et qui a
traversé en expriment aussi leur culture
expriment leur attachement
leur découverte à une spiritualité plus
traditionnels traditionalistes dont qui
ont un peu tout ça dans les communautés
autochtones et parmi les stories ans
qu'on voit à l'écran oui effectivement
j'ai utilisé l'expression costume
d'apparat mais ce sont vous dites des
habits traditionnels
donc c'est ce qu'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on est dans des occasions
particulières ou si on les porte assez
souvent oui on les met dans les
occasions particulières pour recevoir
par exemple des diplomates bon
évidemment pour le pape mais aussi pour
qu'on fait des des cérémonies
traditionnelles
donc on va revêtir leur certains
éléments comme la jeu pour voir
plusieurs dames avec les jeux parus banc
les quartz par exemple mais bien sûr les
chefs vont porter ces coiffes là pour
recevoir la diplomatie donc c'est une
façon d'accueillir l'autre dans ce qu'on
est et de s'affirmer ou six ans quelque
en quelque sorte oui effectivement il y
aura là plusieurs grands chefs au cours
de cette cérémonie qui s'apprête à
commencer le pape est censé présenter
ses excuses dans une demi-heure grosso
modo
il y aura paroisse ou si on aura
peut-être l'occasion de se reparler
isabelle mais on va aller sur le terrain
retrouver will dean est
jeune fille
oui vous avez parlé de ce discours qui
va être un petit peu plus tard
aujourd'hui ça va commencer dans tout ce
qu'une question de minutes la même
seconde elles auront pas vraiment de
pape qui va d'abord visiter un cimetière
de la nation de minsk in et par la suite
il va lorsqu'il sera sur place soit
prendre un moment de silence là un
moment de silence mais aussi de prier
pour que qui ont souffert qui sont morts
pour réfléchir aux histoires qu'il a
entendu je vous rappelle que ce n'est
pas la première fois que le pape
rencontre des survivants à rome il en a
écouté il a vu plusieurs personnes lui
raconter leur histoire par la suite à
18h10 heure locale
il va visiter le site de l'ancien
pensionnat d'1 min skins et les y aura
encore une fois un temps d'arrêt une
pause et eu un moment de silence et si
finalement vers 10h10 heure locale qu'il
y aura ce moment parlant en marquant
plus tôt oui il va s'adresser au peuple
autochtone on s'attend donc à des
excuses de la part du pape normalement
c'est ce qui doit devrait se passer
alors bien sûr c'est qu'un moment
central pour les survivants qui zoo qui
sont sur place afin de voir qu'est ce
que le pape aura comme parole comment
qui va s'adresser aux gens et comment
eux ils vont se sentir
et bien sûr nous on sera sur place avec
des commentaires pour vous et bien sûr
merci
dean est parce qu on voit effectivement
là présent plusieurs générations
d'autochtones on voit des aînés mais on
voit aussi des gens beaucoup plus jeune
donc des survivants qui sont venus
accompagnés de leurs proches
et qui sont venus peut-être accompagnés
de leurs parents s'ils sont encore en
vie et de leurs enfants aussi et ça
c'est important isabelle n'est ce pas
pour pour les nations autochtones oui
absolument vous savez j'aurais été très
surprise de ne voir que des aînés que
des survivants sur les lieux puisque on
le dit depuis quelques minutes déjà les
impacts ils sont multi générationnel
dans les communautés et donc c'est
important que cette écoute leur des
excuses et du pardon du chef de l'église
du pape se passe en famille parce que
c'est toute la communauté qui s'est pas
seulement quelques individus c'est toute
la communauté qui est affecté par les
traumas par les impacts de ce qui s'est
passé dans les pensionnats autochtones
partout à travers le pays donc c'est
normal qu'on voit des gens plus jeunes
des personnes âgées bien sûr je crois
que le pape va dans ses différentes
comédies ou prière parlé du rôle des
aînés et pour les autochtones l'aîné en
place centrale dans la vie sociale oui
absolument l'aîné une place
prépondérante
l'aîné est évidemment de par son
expérience beaucoup de sagesse et le
beaucoup aussi de connaissance
de la terre du territoire de la culture
de la vision du monde lorsque celle ci
au pot été oblitérées évidemment par les
pensionnats mais ils ont un respect de
la plupart des membres de la communauté
et la même chose pour les enfants on
n'en parle pas très souvent mais les
enfants sont au centre des communautés
alors c'est important sont aussi le
comprendre dans les événements qu'on vit
présentement puisque imaginé il ya 150
ans il ya des villages ou du jour au
lendemain on avait plus aucun enfant
alors imaginez la détresse qu'on
pourrait vivre dans la communauté comme
parents comme mère de famille c'est
extrêmement extrêmement difficile
alain crevier j'avais apikaoua alain
crevier dans la recommandation appelle l
action n'a comme sa vérité
réconciliation on voulait que le pape
pour mille des excuses semblable à celle
qui avait été faite aux irlandais et
là quand on parle de l'effet des
pensionnats du système des pensionnats
sont des communautés entières ce que le
pape a reconnu en irlande c'était que
c'était toute l'église et tous ses
fidèles qui ont été entachées parce que
c'était pas si je me suis je me souviens
de cette lettre de benoît 16 et je
trouvais déjà moi personnellement que ce
n'était pas suffisant
oui quand j'ai vu dans la recommandation
58 et dans le reste du travail de la
commission qu'on se référer à s'ancrer
dans un modèle je me dis alors c'est sam
envoie un message c'était faut quand
même se placer dans la peau de ceux qui
vont recevoir ce qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent à voir laquelle quelle est
l'importance des mots qui seront
utilisés je faisais ont pas beaucoup de
pardon qui on comprend là mais il y a
pas que ça le simple fait de sa présence
la dans un lieu comme celui là est
significatif et il parle déjà énormément
et je pense que c'est le plus long
j'étais le plus gros coup que la
commission ou que des autochtones ont
réussi à fin et celui-là demandé à ce
qu'un pape vienne sur le territoire et
la boire vivent avec eux un moment je
pense que les moments de silence va
peut-être plus par là que beaucoup
paroles qu'on pourrait dire autour de sa
présence honnêtement le pardon oui
l'irlande je veux bien mais là il ya
quelque chose de différent il est
vraiment quelque chose de fort qu'est-ce
qu'il fait partie concernant quelle ils
ont réussi les premières nations les
peuples ici on réussit quelque chose je
croyais impensable et réussira là mais
là sur le téléthon ne passionne pas ok
pas dans une église au loin dans un
diocèse où on peut dire tenir debout
discours non en fait c'est ce que c'est
inédit à votre sens qu'un pape comme ça
font dans l'histoire de la papauté
s'excuse e et de le fasse sur les lieux
face à ce qu'il a non c'est à dire que
le pape lui même s'est excusé est à la
bolivie s'est excusé tout au peuple
autochtone de bolivie on se serve jean
paul ii ne fait beaucoup même le no 16
en a fait mais les circonstances ici là
l'ampleur du drame
le rôle de l'église et la façon
d'aborder la chose maintenant de du pape
je trouve que là il ya quelque chose
d'historique à tout le moins pour
l'histoire de ge canada quelque chose là
depuis dans l'histoire de la papauté
aussi belle cause jeudi le feutre fait
tellement de choses mais ça je ne n'ai
pas souvenir d'un truc semblable ou le
pape aurait dit oui ok je vais aller
chez vous m'excusez j'ai pas souvenir de
ça tant que même mort fait des bons
matchs pendant les trois quatre ou cinq
derniers pas plaint jamais vu une chose
comme celle là et puis pour nous
position du canada ces moments moment
très simple escale ce n'est pas
seulement de pardon ce qui m'amène à me
poser la question du parc françois lui
le tap françois vous avez montré qu'on
me prête est difficile pour les gens ce
sécurité parce qu'il en fait quelque
part pas juste à sa tête mais il a une
espèce de spontanéité peut-être est-ce
que lui était ce pas clore sa
personnalité font qu' il est plus ils
étaient plus susceptibles de répondre à
cette demande de venir ici s'explique
croire quand il était plus jeune et
qu'il était provincial des jésuites en
argentine il l'aja mon avis commis des
erreurs et des erreurs de jugement il
était trop jeune dans une situation trop
difficile avec l'armée aux trousses il a
commis des erreurs je pense d'ordre
d'autorité mais il s'en est remis il a
quitté le pouvoir de l'église à ce
moment là et à la campagne il sait je
pense que le moment d'illumination dans
la vie de cet homme là et il est revenu
plus humble plus authentique et quand
les gens de haut niveau dans les divans
dans les bidonvilles je suis allée
moment les bidonvilles le crs et les
jeunes là où il venait souvent ici si
jamais vous le voyez vous
il prenait le temps de s'aimer trop je
pense qu'il a
il ya ça qui s'est développé chez lui
qu'il aura je pense pour beaucoup de
gens authentiques et c'est pour ça que
la présence et peut-être que les
télécharge savez qui vous recevra le
partant tôt membre de la commission
disait que le 1er avril quand le pape
s'est excusé il s'attendait pas à ça il
en est sorti en pleurs
en étant très satisfait des pourtant on
regarde lisez le texte d'excusés aux il
me semble que c'est pas suffisant mais
avec tout devient en pi pi sans compter
le fait qu'on ait nullement ses excuses
depuis belgrade
comme certains m'ont dit le pape ne
vient pas quand les évêques ne le
veulent pas à la posez vous la question
pourquoi ils peuvent nous amener jusqu
ici et ensuite vous vous dites oui mais
pourquoi les évêques ont pris tant de
temps à s'excuser 2021 il ya quelque
chose qui est pas particulièrement clair
on peut juste dire que maintenant les
choses ont changé et que c'est c'est une
occasion rarissime combat lesquels on va
citer on me dit qu'on pourrait aller
joindront à nous non malheureusement
parce qu'on est un collègue vous savez
un cc tombes découvertes à kamloops
l'été dernier ses 215 sépulture anonyme
on était comme un déclencheur d'un éveil
collectif pourtant on savait tout seul
au moins depuis la commission vérité
réconciliation depuis ces travaux il
leur apporte donc publié en décembre
2015 mais cela dit cette découverte des
tombes a été fondamental dans notre
réveil notre prise de conscience
collective et il y a des gens à kamloops
qui aujourd'hui vont suivre ce qui se
passe
à wall street alors je vais les gens de
ma collègue qu'il sur place ce cri durée
de périgny vous êtes là de périgny oui
oui je suis là et je pense que je ne
vous vois pas alors dites-moi des dites
moi comment on attend comment se prépare
à ce discours du pape à ses excuses
écoutez c'est assez mitigé ici en a qui
attendent avec impatience ses excuses
d'autres c'est un peu plus compliqué ça
a fait revivre beaucoup de traumatismes
il ya une délégation dit si qui de
survivants du pensionnats pour
autochtones de kamloops qui s'est rendu
à edmonton hier qui va aujourd'hui
rencontrer le pape qui est très
enthousiaste à l'idée de recevoir ses
excuses pensionnats pour autochtones de
kamloops qui était le plus grand
pensionnats pour autochtones du canada
il ya eu jusqu'à 500 élèves dans les
années 1950 dans cet établissement je
sais pas si vous nous voyez oui on est
en ce moment au pensionnat et on va vous
montrer un peu l'établissement à quoi il
ressemble la cheffe casimir avait à la
base invité le pape françois à venir ici
voir l'établissement à venir rencontrer
en personne à kamloops les survivants
pour qu'ils puissent voir cet
établissement de leurs yeux à travers
leurs expériences leurs traumatismes
qu'ils ont vécu ici bon finalement c'est
la chef casimir et 14 survivants qui se
rendent à edmonton pour le rencontrer
mais il ya quand même beaucoup d'
enthousiasme parce qu'on dit que l'on
souhaite avoir des excuses beaucoup plus
larges que celles qui ont été prononcées
dans le souverain pontife lorsqu'il
était au vatican au printemps on dit
qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de conversations
encore à voir avec le pape a notamment
au sujet des levées de fonds pour les
survivants pour les registres aussi
l'accès à ces documents des pensionnats
pour autochtones qui vont permettre
d'identifier les enfants disparus dans
tous ses établissements ailleurs dans la
communauté à part ces délégations je
vous disais c'est assez mitigé je
parlais avec un autre représentant d'une
première nation du secteur la première
nation bonaparte dont les survivants
sont aussi venus dans cet établissement
et lui me disait que sur 85 aînés de la
communauté il y en a que sept qui ont
décidé d'aller demain tonnes voir le
pape pour les autres il ya encore
beaucoup de colère ont dit qu'on en a
assez des excuses mais ce qu'on veut
c'est des actions des actions de
l'église mais aussi du gouvernement et
ces actions vous l'avez mentionné
brièvement c'est de l'argent pour le
dédommagement et de l'accès à des
documents c'est ça
c'est ça des levées de fonds pour les
survivants pour autochtones l'axé
surtout à ces registres acquis une
demande qui a été faite maintes fois par
les communautés autochtones on demande
aussi une reconnaissance de tous les
torts qui ont été faits d une
reconnaissance vraiment plus sincère de
tous les torts qui ont été causés par
l'église dans ces établissements donc
c'est plus que je suis désolé c'est
vraiment des actions est aussi avoir une
marche à suivre pour la suite des choses
pour la guérison des survivants alors
qu'ils puissent aller de l'avant et de
pots pour qu'ils puissent mener à bien
ce projet de réconciliation pas
seulement eux personnellement mais aussi
avec la communauté canadienne et que
tout le monde puisse mener à bien ce
processus merci beaucoup que will de
durée de piri renfort
alors on a vu le pape arrivé en fauteuil
roulant on a aperçu aussi
michèle audette on a vu jack médecine le
premier truc très doué sur place là
c'est un tambour d'accueil du pape en
écoute
à
oh
à m
[Musique]
et
barilla
ah
[Musique]
ah ah
ah
[Musique]
et
m
et à la r1
e
[Musique]
et à
ea
m
[Musique]
e
1 et
et à la
haye
et à
[Musique]
m
e
à
[Musique]
il
je
alors vous avez vu le pape françois on
s'est tous dit ici que c'était quand
même
une image extraordinaire on parle d'un
homme de dieu qui a consacré la vie à la
prière et à l'église et qui se regarde
qui se retrouve sous l'oeil des caméras
du monde entier avec tout un cortège
aussi assez remarquable d'hommes qui
semble assurer à la fois sa sécurité qui
sont à son service pour ce serait qu'il
a tout ce qui lui faut je crois aussi
qu'il l'avait l'heure de manger un petit
bonbon
pour s'hydrater parce qu'il devra
prendre la parole tout à l'heure et que
ce seront des paroles importante le pape
première station ce cimetière ce
cimetière où la prière sera silencieuse
ce cimetière où sont enterrés des morts
les pensionnaires mort à ce seul ancien
pensionnat der mesquine mais aussi des
religieux et des membres des communautés
environnantes
le pape se recueille donc en silence
dans ce cimetière
à l'aise cette pierre je suis un peu ça
fait partie de cette image d'
authentiques le pape qui est en train de
construire en vue de ses excuses qui va
présenter vos amis tous les deux a
commenté malcom
je suis sûr que disney c'est la genèse
et ça m'a pris j'ai vu aussi faire un
geste comme celui là qui a marqué
probablement mon esprit de l'image de
son tout son pontificat de jean paul ii
a eu des moments aussi six ans comme ça
vous n'a de france soir dans une
situation un événement
inusité
et il est tout seul là il est il est en
avant il ya personne pour le distraire
de ce qu'il voit de ce cimetière
et je conseille le botnet de vous mettre
dans son choix
pensez à la sécurité vous non non je
pense à lui
capable d'envoyer premier manque un
saboteur
m'a très particulier
il semble poser ses mains d'une certaine
façon d'accord avant le signe de la
croix
alors la prière est temps de
recueillement silencieux étant terminé
il doit maintenant se rendre directement
sur le site de l'ancien pensionnaire de
minsk in
il a eu fort à une prière saura-t-elle
silencieuse sur la tel public
elle sera bref
isabelle picard ton vous voyez ces
images là qu'est ce que quels sont vos
réflexions
or c'est une bonne question
moi pour moi je j'attends la suite
j'attends la suite évidemment j'ai vu un
homme un homme priée de façon horrible
il était seul
face à ce cimetière leur
mai mais pour moi ça reste une prière
tout va être dans la suite dans les
actions
j'attends beaucoup plus que ça de la
part du saint père oui je pense que vous
n'êtes pas la seule autochtone à penser
comme ça alors oui alors on le voit donc
il quitte le cimetière de mai dernier
skins en route comme je vous le disais
pour le site de l'ancien pensionnat
où il doit passer
cinq minutes sans c'est un horaire quand
même qu'ils découper au couteau la même
s'il a pris un léger retard on arrive en
3 minutes je crois en retard c'est
vraiment un horaire suivi de très près
alors on le voit à l'est derrière lui il
semble y avoir des gens d'église rare
s'est lassé de l'archevêque de moncton
qui est là juste à côté
qu'on voit un style gauche à droite
youtube oui
et puis enfin que c'est à peu près le
seul digne et de terre
dans les rangs dans les hiérarchies que
je vois autour de moi
et pourtant on a vu un peu plus tôt
moment de l'accueil ont 9 u 15 le wallet
on a vu qu'à la guerre on a vu des
grands personnages qu'on avait son
cercle restreint des grands diplomates
de l'aider et l on les a vus mais là
c'est autre chose c'est moi qui je les
ai qui appartient au par françoise soit
plus mal choisi comme on le met on
comprend que c'est
sur lui que toute l'attention
alors on a vu une image
aérienne on comprenait que la route
voilà la route sur lequel les se déplace
la rue sur lequel ils se déplacent et
bordé d'un côté par ses tipis qui ont
remplacé
l'ancien pensionnat sais j'ai bien
compris isabelle je sais pas si vous
êtes au courant mais c'est typique ont
été érigées donc sur le site de l'ancien
pensionnat oui effectivement ça fait
partie du processus de guérison que de
se réapproprier le territoire de façon à
culturellement respectable de façon plus
traditionnelle et c'est c'est une façon
que trouver cette ses premières nations
en fait pour le faire
t
sous sa table
alors on existe hier alain que le parc
promettait on le voyait remettre des
petites boîtes rouges habituellement ce
sont des cadeaux toujours les mêmes
bases parce que c'est des chapelets
bénis par le pape
c'est pas les mêmes chefs les cours
trouvent leur place saint piat la mesure
où si un changement de nom oui d'accord
oui vraiment dans un monde diplomatique
les six parce que a placé un carré sont
pas tous bénie par le vent n'ont pas
vraiment croire le poids
et c'est chef isabelle à ce que vous les
reconnaissez est-ce que ce qu'on vient
de voir sa ville pape oui oui en a
quelques-uns que je peux reconnaître en
fait ce sont les chefs du traité numéro
6 lors de la confédération street 0,6 il
y avait parmi eux vers l'homme
saddleback y avait un birman skins ou si
ce sont deux des chefs que j'ai que
c'est plus reconnaître mais c'est normal
dans le protocole que ce soit les
chiffres du territoire où le diplomate
dans ce cas ci le parc se présente qui
accueille donc le pape de façon
individuelle oui parce qu'il faut saisir
le pensionnat a retrouvé son nom
autochtone et mesquine et on est en
territoire autochtone la symbolique est
d'autant plus forte aujourd'hui ah oui
absolument absolument c'est c'est le
trottoir le territoire du traité numéro
6 on y ont mis tout près de plusieurs
communautés autochtones qu'elle soit
riche qu'elle soit si one ou gibout est
donc évidemment on se doit d'accueillir
deux façons protocolaire le par laquelle
politique des chefs
je vois le pape allait le pack qui a
rattrapé comment ce qu'on appelle le
chapeau c'est le capitaine sa capitale
une ville en ville a décidé de l'enlever
finalement ces fonds la donne aussi ah
oui oui oui les champs les fendre les
gens les pèlerins qui vont à rome
achètent des trucs très semblables puis
ils acceptent des échanges est alors de
tout
avec la cabine spatiale des fans comme
pour une rock star la plus triste
parfois là dedans jouer alors on voit le
pape qui à nouveau ce recueil cette fois
c'est c'est devant le site de l'ancien
pensionnat permet ce kane
là où donc on a vu tout à l'heure où si
des tipis qui ont été érigées
donc on aura conclu que sa prière que la
prière ils devaient faire il était
question qu'elle puisse être publiques
qu'elles soient peut-être public mais je
crois que le pape a décidé de la faire
en silence de se recueillir en silence
à la mémoire de ce qui s'est passé dans
ce pensionnat un des plus grands du pays
maintenant de pape se rend sur le site
du paroisse où ça isabelle vous allez
devoir nous expliquer toute la richesse
du sens de parole on parle d'un cercle
paroisse ou alors le noeud pap istres a
conduit on va retrouver il a
éventuellement des chants des tambours
des danseurs mais aussi les grands chefs
qui il y en a quelques 250 qui sont
attendus qui vont entrer dans ce cercle
du parwan dans lequel le pape lui-même
sera assis
expliqué nous rappelle l'importance du
poids ou vous savez en étant saison
estivale évidemment des parois il y en a
dans presque toutes les communautés
maintenant à travers le canada c'est un
moment où on peut se rassembler comme
premiers peuples principalement comme
première nation puisqu'il n'est pas de
façon égale celle et chez les inuits et
c'est un moment où on célèbre par la
danse par le tambour par la nourriture
par l'artisanat c'est pas au world banks
et un concours de danse mais c'est
beaucoup plus que cela c'est un élément
très spirituel qui
selon moi fait partie des éléments de
guérison de fait dotée cette communauté
où ces communautés le dernier ce qui
n'en fait pour rétablir un peu le bal en
un ballon un peu plus positif de ce qui
s'est passé en lien avec avec les
pensionnats autochtones et donc il va y
avoir une grande entrée avec le les
chefs évidemment et par la suite on
pourra entendre le tambour et avoir des
danseurs henri galy à pratiquer les
danses différents dans ce qu'on fait
pendant les parois dit mlle paroisse ce
que je me trompe pas c'est pas un mot
d'origine algonquine sa paroisse oui
c'est un mode original contiennent
effectivement mais je ne saurais pas
vous dire exactement laquelle des là où
vous savez qu'il ya quand même 90
langues autochtones au canada et c'est
un mot qui a été emprunté par plusieurs
premières nations même si les voix en
date on ne veut pas voir donc qu'on
nomme de cette façon là puisque c'est
pas le mot comme tel qui veut qui veut
dire quelque chose comme rassemblement
mais c'est plutôt justement l'action ce
qui se passe pendant le rassemblement
justement c'est dans cela dont on parle
ce recueillement aussi cet aspect très
spirituelle dont je parlais potable mais
le par wes qu'il est convoqué
régulièrement à la même date chaque
année ou s'il est convoqué pour des
occasions spéciales
oui normalement c'est à peu près à la
même date à chaque année
yo ce qu'on appelle chemin et les parois
ou la route et paoua ont peu partout à
travers le canada et les danseurs de pas
voir se promènent d'événement en
événement
pour pouvoir danser c'est c'est
également des concours donc c'est une
façon pour certains de gagner leur vie
évidemment quand on reçoit le pape ou
qui ont une autre activité très
importante
on peut faire un pas voir justement à
court pour l'événement
alors donc comme des danseurs attitré
qui dès qu'ils qui le font en qui
s'habille dans des tenues de louis et
autant les hommes les femmes les enfants
il ya différentes catégories on danse
par catégorie d'âge ah oui oui et par et
part dans ce dont vous avez différentes
danses
du chat le tweak basse bien différent
denses et donc selon les clochettes par
exemple chez les femmes et selon ses on
est un danseur de clochettes et qu'on a
24 ans ben on va on va pratiquer la
danse à certains moments et sinon assez
on est un aîné c'est un peu plus tard et
il ya des il ya des concours comme ça
par catégorie et vous parlez aussi de
nourriture bon il ya évidemment c'est
les tenues l'amusé que les tambours les
chante et on évoque quoi danser challah
en fait c'est souvent ça dépend des fois
mais c'est souvent un effet de se
rassembler la force vous allez
l'entendre tout à l'heure il va y avoir
plusieurs hommes autour d'un grand
tambour et vous allez entendre la force
je n'aurais même pas besoin de vous
expliquer ce qu'on peut prendre quelques
secondes en fait pour entendre quand ce
sera le temps vous allez comprendre
on évoque le
le lien aussi avec le territoire le lien
avec les ancêtres je vous disais que
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
spirituel c'est pas seulement des
concours de danse c'est beaucoup plus
que ça donc il ya un aspect de
recueillement d'être ensemble lien avec
les ancêtres avec l'histoire et donc
c'est tout à fait approprié pour la
visite du parc est ce que est ce qu'ils
ont déjà ses jeux ses parois étaient
présidés par
des guérisseurs justement des chamans aa
s'est pas vraiment comme ça que ça se
passe comme tel évidemment on va laisser
une place prépondérante aux aînés à part
dans les power notamment ceux qui ont
fait les guerres donc la deuxième guerre
mondiale la guerre de bon peu importe
les guerres on va leur laisser
un espace particulier aux aînés mais à
ma connaissance
moi j'ai revisité au québec en tout cas
que ce soit un guérisseur ou comme vous
l'appelez un chaman qui va présider le
power ça n'existe pas ça chez les
populations autochtones du canada des
chemins
alors ça c'est pas comme ça qu'on les
appelle oui mais vous savez il ya quand
même 700 communauté autochtone à travers
le canada incluant les inuits donc c'est
difficile de savoir tout ce qui se passe
partout il y a évidemment des aînés
guérisseur relative des rituels oui mais
le manche ammann est un mot russe donc
qui vient plus des autochtones de
l'artiste d'accord alors on voit cette
longue procession dans le fond mais
le pape se retrouve maintenant
accompagnée par certains des chefs
autochtones
qui sont venus
oh pas ton fauteuil roulant le pape de
85 ans le ballon genou
qui doit on s'y est habitué avec jean
paul ii à quelque chose d'autre ici on
ne fait pas ce sentiment que cet homme
diminué de santé là j'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils traînent çà de là
sur la place publique comme c'était ton
chemin croit jean paul 2 c'était un
message qui n'en méritait vive jusqu'à
la dernière jusqu'à son dernier souffle
ici j'ai pas cette impression là j'ai
l'impression contrat de quelqu'un qui
est qui est pris avec un corps qui
l'obligent à rouler comme ça et je
n'aurais je pas prêt à faire ce qu'il
veut faire non je pense que non
il a il a pourtant décrit ce voyage je
sais pas pourquoi je fais l'association
mais je pense qu'elle est pas si folle
il est pourtant décrit ce voyage que le
voyage de pénitence ou si un voyage si
need ans et pas seulement un pèlerinage
ont serpenté leur image mois ses amis ou
de se recueillir tout simplement
on imite ans oui mais vous avez le tout
la signification du voyage supporteurs
ici le lieu la géographie la présence
est tellement importante est ce qu'elle
est plus important que les mousses pour
moi de répondre à ça mais pour ça que je
dis c'est unique ce n'est pas le pape
qui vient à la demande de
deux des catholiques de pays quelconque
pour venir les saluer voir comment ils
vont puis faire acte de présence
encourager les gens à der garde et
d'ailleurs je lis doit y avoir beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion et l'expectative
dans cette danse est telle qu'on a
appelée là où quelques 6000 personnes
sont censées demi l'intérieur quatre
mines extérieurs sont censés être
présente alors que le pape approche on
le voit avec les grands chefs au pont au
fond c'est ça devrait pas tarder les
excuses qu'il est censé présenter à
tandis que je regarde
l'ordre du jour on aperçoit le premier
ministre trudeau
je pense celui qui va accueillir le pape
sait si oui ni oui ni les ruelles je
pense que c'est lui donc xmame delà de
la commission celui qui a eu cette idée
étrange whipple à l'action à 58
moyennement et aux pattes ne s'excusant
été commis stade a comme sa vérité
réconciliation et scénic a dit fou qui
fonctionne dans ses pensionnaires le
faux pas et assume il a d'ailleurs alors
c'est lequel je pense qu'on va le voir
j'ai l'impression que c'est lui qui va
accueillir le pape je sais que c'est lui
qui va lui passer la parole
on y descend
on voit la gouverneure générale
mérite steinen elle-même
inouk
je
alors ce masque watts hitchcock c'est un
lieu traditionnel c'est là qu'on se font
les parois ou c'est pas le premier
parloir masse kasich par isabelle
en fait non c'est pas le premier
pour parler par dossier le pat je suis
là
écoutez
d'abord dit non plus si ward swing et
banquiers oui nos excès liga notamment
webster et wimax ou evo x rite aid and
or qui a lancé ce moment tant ce sera
systématique
excitant comme vos gamineries
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
des matches
comme ça
la tortue incarnent en fait représente
le symbole du battement de coeur de la
mère nature et de toutes les personnes
qui sont ré nous avons tous des
battements de coeur cela représente le
battement de coeur de tous les animaux
de tous les êtres vivants donc c'est
quelque chose de très puissant qui nous
guérit et à nouveau c'est en après midi
particulièrement
particulier et c'est une chanson sacré
qui permet de présenter notre grand
visiteurs alors
nous allons honorer nos chefs
qui viendront ne l'est ici donc c'est ce
actuelle et au sud ce seront nos anciens
chefs alors pour le moment nous allons
donc chantier une grande chanson une
grande chanson d'entrée quelques nous
n'appelons
[Musique]
[Rires]
d'ailleurs
les 17 jan hommen aurélie challes
mesdames et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les chefs de tous nos nations
ont des personnels avec les aigles qui
mène la procession
donc les
il représente notre souveraineté non
nations qui seront pas représentés par
en fait l'aigle qui incarne tout à fait
l'histoire de nour nation est représenté
par ces coiffes donc nous donnons la
bienvenue à nos grands chefs nos grands
chefs qui porte et des coiffes de guerre
qui sont très sacré à nos yeux des
bonnets de gars qui incarne le
leadership le leadership de nos nations
de leadership parmi toutes nos nations
donc le bonnet de l'aigle la coiffe de
legs représentent que nous sommes en
tant que nation
[Applaudissements]
sorry we gonna fall et je suis ici nous
avons nos chefs qui se présentent ici
au guingois comme bienvenue aux
mascottes eu bienvenue à nouveau à mas
quoi si ce
[Musique]
geste de le camp 4 nations et aussi nos
grands chefs dr
jory jeh johnson
alors mesdames messieurs de ce côté
là
l'est qui représente le soleil le soleil
donne la vie le soleil donne la santé
le soleil est la chose la plus puissante
que le créateur nous est donné en tant
que personne en tant que peuples des
premières nations
nous reconnaissons le soleil qui nous
guérit qui nous donne la bonne santé
[Musique]
nous avons ancien chef mais également
la prochaine audience chez vie nous
avons ici tous les chefs de nos
territoires
donc les chefs daisy tant d'autres en
visite d'autres nations en costume et en
quoi ça
me
prenait jamais de tourner thomas est le
mot canada john lee grady mia est
troisième avec matthew morrison iranien
et en asie note me lagarde concernant
minogue est capé novosti
un contre meeting est au fondement qui
grouille
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
come
back
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
com
et
[Musique]
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ouais
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs nous pouvons
applaudir chaleureusement les musiciens
oui je deviens alors mesdames et
messieurs ici présents ici nous avons
plus maintien nous avons les bâtons et
qui incarnent les guerriers nous devons
défendre nos territoires nos guerriers
devait défendre nos langues il devait
défendre nos enfants nos petits-enfants
nous devions défendre notre langue nous
devions défendre notre mode de vie donc
ce sont des matons qui incarnent ces
représentations mais aussi ce sont des
gens qui représentent le leadership
alors aujourd'hui nous allons
rendre hommage à nos chefs avec une
chanson
[Musique]
à
après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous demandez de demander de chanter une
dernière chanson le chansons de la
victoire
une chanson de la victoire alors que
nous rendons hommage vous savez nous
sommes ici depuis des temps immémoriaux
du tout nous sommes aujourd'hui en 2022
et nous avons toujours nos modes de vie
nos langages nos langues et nous allons
continuer à vivre selon ses modes de vie
c'est une chanson de la victoire
donc nous avons d'abord nos chefs et
leurs coiffes et leurs bâtons
l'appel de la guerre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
once again rognage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces vols
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
certes à poser
nous allons maintenant avoir une danse
de guérison je voudrais que en fait les
éléments auront été
vous savez les sacs le représente en
fait la fille depuis le début des colons
parcours ce cheval donc à nouveau
nous avons nos principales ce coton nous
avons en fait ces principales cérémonies
au milieu de nous toutes les nations se
réunissent pour
remercier le créateur tout le monde
doit jeûner pendant trois quatre jours
tout le monde danse sans manger sans
boire
ici cela représente justement tu
t'ennuies oui mesdames et messieurs vous
pouvez venir maintenant à l'avant
[Applaudissements]
on approche du moment tant attendu le
pape s'apprête à prononcer des mots d'
excuses
mais on entendra auparavant
vraisemblablement les mots de bienvenue
par le chef willie et au tchad
dont alain crevier nous disait tout à
l'heure qu'il est lui-même
survivants
qui a su résister et quand on dit
survivre il a vraiment survécu au
pensionnat est devenue maintenant à
l'unc je vous laisse poursuivre dire qui
est ce willy les torchères ce chef qui
était ainsi tout à l'heure
pour nous à la droite du pape à
l'extrême droite et qui je vous le
rappelle doit prononcer donc ses mots de
bienvenue alors alain crise willy de
charles et au tchad comme beaucoup de
personnes ce sont les noms de ceux qui
sont jamais revenus les cendres ont mené
ces salles et les dix morts des
pensionnaires mais exact et les autres
chaînes et est entré dans ce pensionnat
à l'âge de six ans
il a réussi dit il à éviter les
agresseurs autant que possible en
faisant du sport il voulait pas devenir
un nouveau logiciel ou même de faire
autre chose que je voulais devenir un
joueur acquis comme ça surtout ça se
fait
tout le monde de se voir
tel voir je sais que nous avons de
grands écrans mais je suis tenons
vraiment à voir
sa sainteté
et à l'entendre
alors on invite les gens à s'asseoir
pour que tous les opus voir et entendre
pendant que la banderole donc avec le
nom de tous les disparus des pensionnats
et on n'a pas fini d'en découvrir des
disparus parce qu'on sait pas tout n'est
ce pas isabelle l'on sait pas on ne sait
pas combien y en avait on ne sait pas
combien sont morts effectivement il ya
des 2800 dons qui ont été dévoilés
quelques semaines déjà mais les
estimations sont au moins au minimum à
six millions de personnes ces normes
voilà les touches à nantes on parlait
tant tout fait partie de ceux qui avec
un radar particulier lille où seul de sa
région il on trouve effectivement des
camps il en a même trouvé une déterré un
cercueil d'un avenant garçons de 6 à
baisser beaucoup vu le dos qui est entré
concernant l'âge de six ans et c'est
qu'ils ont fait d'une cérémonie
approprié pour pour ce qu' ils avaient
trouvé la mort ya une identification de
directeur il a vécu les personnels il
trouve maintenant des tombes et
demandent au pape donne et s'excuser et
c'est ce moment là le chrono sous les
yeux
un moment très attendu mais en même
temps on attendait 6000 personnes gerbe
qu'on ait des décomptes peut-être en
nous n'aurons nous pas mais il devait y
avoir deux mille personnes à l'intérieur
de ce cercle et 4000 à l'extérieur
je ne les ai pas compter évidemment je
suis pas mesure de le faire mais
l'impression que je sais que ces peuples
et le sud de l'ancien pensionnat
l'époque l'est
il paraît que fait très mauvais plus tôt
il n'y a plus énormément à ce que ça a
découragé
[Musique]
sept personnes de venir entendre le pape
ou si c'est tout simplement un sentiment
de colère un sentiment d'indifférence à
l'égard de ses excuses qui se manifeste
ici a suivi de
thomas
elgin et sinon sweet home chicago
et pina arcamone
mcsween milanello pepe
jeans
auxerroise sont
là pour nous le rappeler
sweeney l'axé d'après ap le
contexte et la nasscom qui n'a pas pu
commencer
par
cocteau ne les comprend pas d'être a
tenu a résumé alain giresse que vous en
penser elles mais quelque chose a vendu
à l'envoyer lire mais dont il n'a pas
accès ce qui ce dit la nôtre c'est mal
on dit que les papes qu'elle m'apporte
définition c'est déjà knapp plusieurs la
petite lettre je viens c'est que son
année dépassant pas 100 français sur à
la leçon prix je ne sais pas trop mais
il doit y avoir un sam de communication
qui lui permet à tout le moins de
comprendre le contenu général de ce qui
se dit et on s'attend d'ailleurs à ce
que sept de ces paroles qu'ils
prononcent ils le fassent en espagnol
dans sa langue maternelle n'est ce pas
en espagnol en italien très à l'aise
peut le faire aussi à la limite certains
disent peut-être mais les prières point
de vue il ya eu des moments où il était
en méditation peut-être que c'était des
prières en latin qui nous reste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
noda
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
faudrait que
les quatre modes de vie
les quatre direction du vent
nous avons le lever du soleil à l'est
et nous avons également au sud nous
avons
l'oiseau tonnerre et à l'ouest nous
avons les bons l'oxygène que nous
respirons
c'est le gouvernement de mère nature de
la mer terre et au nord nous avons la
mer
c'est ce que nous incarnons ce que nous
sommes mère nature ce sont toutes les
plantes la vie des plantes notre mère
notre maire est également
la mère de tous les insectes qui vole
le maire est également seul de tous les
animaux
sur terre dans l'air dans l'eau la mère
terre bien évidemment et la mère de
toute l'humanité de tous les êtres
humains mais blatter est ce que nous
sommes nous sommes les enfants nous
sommes les peuples de la mer à terre
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors isabelle j'aimerais faire appel à
vos connaissances d'ethnologue on a
accès à toutes sortes de symbolique on a
entendu parler des points cardinaux là
on voit une danse qu'est ce que c'est
tout ça à la danseuse convient de voir
elle fait la danse du charles juste
avant c'était la danse des clash est
donc ce n'est pas proprement une
démonstration de danse de parloir convoi
jeudi
évidemment on représente toujours les
pointeurs pilonné quatre éléments
dans tout ce qu'on fait au niveau
cérémoniel au niveau autochtone à
oiseaux c'est assez commun à travers
tout le pays effectivement
et la danse du char c'est un classique
des paroles oui oui c'est un classique
comme la danse des clochettes très
populaire
[Musique]
donné la bienvenue parmi nous
vous avez entamé un long voyage pour
être avec nous sur nos terres un témoin
et pour marcher ensemble avec pour
suivre le pas de la réconciliation eu
lieu voilà pourquoi nous vous rendons
hommage et nous vous présentons nous
vous accueillons vraiment très
chaleureusement ici nous tenons à vous
faire vous présenter notre gratitude
mais en version des grands efforts que
vous avez à lyon de plus au pouvoir vous
rendre sur notre terre c'est vraiment il
m'aider mais détection de vous re
recevoir parmi nous
le canada que
ce que les premières nations appel à
lille de la torture ou les territoires
des premières nations des métis les
inuits
moscovici hamas quoi ces études nous
nous trouvons sur les terres visées par
le traité 6 les
territoires des cris des blagues food et
des d'edena cotation des seaux d'eau
depuis des temps immémoriaux
une grille noire en crise je m'appelle
mike à noter que celui qui marche avec
les loups convenu mais aussi l'aigle
d'or en anglais
m'appelle
j'ai été élève ici à l'ancien
pensionnats pour autochtones terminé
donc jusqu'à ce jour lorsque vous
faisons toutes les premières nations et
sir les anciens ici au pays nous sommes
réunis ici avec les personnes les
habitants de max baucus les survivants
des pensionnats pour autochtones les
chefs les dirigeants les aînés les
gardiens du savoir et les jeunes des
premières nations des communautés des
premières nations des inuits et des
métis de tout le pays et nous nous
sentons particulièrement honorés de vous
donner la bière de donner la bienvenue
également à la gouverneure générale du
canada son excellence mary simon ainsi
que le premier ministre le très
honorable justin trudeau
en tant qu ancien commissaire
au fond dans lequel titre d'anciens
commissaires de la commission de vérité
et de réconciliation
j'ai entendu le témoignage de
pratiquement 70 mille anciens
témoignages d'anciens élèves des
pensionnats pour autochtones de ces pays
pendant notre visite à l'occasion notre
visite au vatican avec une délégation
d'anciens élèves de gardiens du savoir
des nez de jeunes vous avez également
entendu les abus que beaucoup d'entre
nous avons subi
ici à ce pensionnat mais ailleurs aussi
dans d'autres pensionnat pendant que
nous étions avec vous il était manifeste
à nos yeux tout ce que vous avez écouté
très profondément avec une grande
compassion le témoignage qui vous ont
ils décrient la suppression de nos
langues de nos cultures qui nous ont été
arrachés
mais aussi notre spiritualité qui a été
dénigré
notre spiritualité qui a été dénigré
vous avez entendu la dévastation qui a
suivi après que nous ayons été arraché à
nos familles
les mots que vous avez prononcé en
réponse
provenaient manifestement du fond de
votre coeur et pour ceux qui les ont
entendus ils ont été une source de grand
confort et de l'encouragement à cette
occasion vous avez fait part de votre
intention de vous rendre sur notre terre
et de cette façon de vous exprimer votre
volonté d'être proche de nous et
maintenant
saint père vous êtes venus sur nos
terres vous avez répondu à notre
invitation comme à notre invitation
comme vous l'aviez promis vous aviez dit
que vous veniez comme pèlerin qui
cherchait à marcher avec nous sur le
chemin de la vérité de la justice de là
guérison de la réconciliation et de
l'espoir
nous vous donnons la bienvenue sur ce
parcours vers la guérison alors que vous
avez vous avez parlé à rome nous en tant
qu'auto donne peuples autochtones nous
avons toujours essayé de tenir compte
des effets du président des événements
du présent
et de leurs incidences sur les
générations futures
dans cet esprit nous espérons vraiment
que notre rencontre d'aujourd'hui et les
paroles que vous allez prononcer devant
nous feront écho à cette dérision vont
apporter vraiment de laisse voir aux
prochaines générations
bienvenue saint pair sur nos terres
[Applaudissements]
bon
si le
gouverneur général monsieur le premier
ministre
cheikh peuples autochtones vivent et de
masse quoi sur et de cette terre
canadienne
chers frères gers à
dos j'attendais ce moment pour être
parmi vous qui
devez d'ici de ce lieu tristement il
faut 14
je voudrais entamé ce qui habite mon âme
on n'a plus le pèlerinage un pèlerinage
les neet en ciel je viens sur vos terres
natales
pour vous dire dolivo personnellement
que je suis a fléchi pour un pli
implorer dieu pour le pardon la guérison
motivé la réconciliation la mire pour
vous manifester ma proximité
pour prier avec nous comme pour vous
associer
à
benton chômage
y avait comme tournée de france tout a
lieu in person of my soul
to go
info
le thinkcentre une
rencontre à rome il y a quatre
alors on m'avait remis comme cadeau de
paire de mocassins signe de la
souffrance endurée par les enfants
autochtones
particulièrement
la souffrance de ceux qui
malheureusement le sont charnues f
jamais revenu à la maison des
pensionnats pour autochtones on m'a
demandé de rapporter les mocassins tu
quand j'arriverai au canada je les ai
apporté avec moi et je les rendrai après
ce discours
et je voudrais justement m'inspirer de
ce symbole il dans les mois qui viennent
de s'écouler ont ravivé en moins la
douleur l'indignation et la
souvenir de ses enfants
suscite une douleur et insistent à agir
pour que chaque enfant soit traité avec
amour honneur et respect
mais ces mocassins nous parle aussi d'un
cheminement d'un parcours que nous
voulons suivre ensemble marcher ensemble
prier ensemble
travailler ensemble pour que les
souffrances du passé cède la place à un
aveu un avenir de justice de guérison et
de réconciliation
traduction en anglais
et
ce
n'est
pas tout
in dignity and shame
vos memory of the children in the deep
in four heroes lost world tour in short
and every child is love en egypte
à
112 magasins
sous spi tu as va pas trop fort
johnny d'art weeds how to meet again
we want
to try to give in to gaza so that the
rings the past cannelito if you just
kidding elle aura qu'une seule liste
était surmotivé
et c'est pour cela que la première étape
de mon pèlerinage parmi vous se déroule
dans cette région qui a vu depuis des
temps immémoriaux
la présence de peuples autochtones
c'est un territoire qui nous parle qui
nous permet de faire mémoire
faire mémoire mes frères mes soeurs vous
avez vécu sur cette terre pendant des
milliers d'années selon des modes de vie
respectueux de la terre elle-même
hérités de génération passée et
conserver pour les générations futures
vous l'avez traité comme un don du
créateur à partager avec les autres et à
aimer en harmonie avec tout ce qui
existe dans une vivante relations avec
tous les êtres vous allez ainsi appris à
nourrir un sens de familles et de
communautés
et vous avez développé des liens solides
entre les générations en honorant les
personnes âgées et en prenant soin des
plus petits que de bonnes coutumes et
d'enseignement centré sur l'attention
aux autres et l'amour de la vérité
sur le courage et le respect l'humilité
et l'honnêteté sur la sagesse de la vie
traduction industry jh williams iii mots
et mémoriaux hassine de personnes avec
des
designs tatzpit tu as des bosses to
remember
remember brothers and sisters
the
past génération harkis ping forte hausse
yet to come you have read a sign of
three years to be cheyrou et ziani
existe un profond
de soi
à sense of fame and community and to
build soul band between génération en or
in your eyes crying freeman
est réjouissante castor entities
centrone qu'une seule fois à tous je
refuse car jean respecte je me relis en
estie
pakistan
le premier leur passé mais c'était là
les premiers pas posé sur ces
territoires
la mémoire elle nous ramène tristement
ce qui s'est passé après l'endroit où
nous nous trouvons maintenant fait
résonner en moins un cri de douleur un
cri étouffé
qui m'a accompagné tout au long des
derniers mois
je repense au drame subi par tant
d'entre vous par vos familles par vous
communauté à ce que vous m'avez raconter
sur les souffrances endurées dans les
pensionnats pour autochtones
ce sont des traumatismes qui d'une
certaine manière ressurgissent tu chaque
fois qu'on y pense et je me rends compte
que même notre rencontre aujourd'hui
peut raviver des souvenirs et des
blessures et que beaucoup d'entre vous
se sentent peut-être en difficulté au
moment même où je vous parle mais il est
juste de faire mémoire car l'oubli
conduit à l'indifférence et on l'a dit
le contraire de l'amour peut vraiment la
haine c'est l'indifférence le contraire
de la vie ce n'est pas la mort c'est
l'indifférence à la vie ou à la mort
nous souvenir des expériences
dévastatrice qui se sont déroulées dans
les pensionnats pour autochtones nous
atteint nous indigne et nous fait mal
mais c'est nécessaire
dans
ce
domaine
et leurs familles et nous avons
envoyé chez louise mais à bordeaux sa
fraîcheur et
désormais par un seul week end we never
too
many review mayfield comme robben et van
aal fille y est here is right to remain
bykov sprunger fournissent vitrine de
france l as he has been made by ap 09 19
h reid et cindy france
2 france
trimestre et d'une expérience
d'actrice et de
ressources car ce pays est niet il est
nécessaire
ou pas nécessaire et mila sûr de se
rappeler à quel point les politiques
d'assimilation et d'affranchissement qui
comprenait également le système des
pensionnats pour autochtones ont été
dévastatrices pour les habitants de
cette terre
lorsque les colons européens sont
arrivés ici pour la première fois
alors c'est tout vert une grande
occasion de développer une rencontre
fructueuse entre les cultures les
traditions et la spiritualité
mais dans une large mesure cela ne s'est
pas produit et vos récits me reviennent
à l'esprit
comment les politiques d'assimilation
finit par marginalisés systématiquement
les peuples autochtones
comment de même à travers le système des
pensionnats pour autochtones
vous langue vos cultures ont été
dénigrés est supprimé
comment les enfants ont subi des sévices
physiques et verbaux psychologique et
spirituel comment ils ont été arrachés à
leur foyer quand il était petit et
comment cela a marqué de façon
indélébile les relations entre parents
et enfants grands-parents et
petits-enfants
en anglais
sur des choses elles forment obscur
joaillerie y est fortement aux portes
d'athènes arabe
haegen writing pas quand de story sur
aude au repos
simulation et les systèmes avec lui
mauroy il signe un
10.26
rayonnages
indalo affecte
remercie de m'avoir fait entrer au coeur
de tout cela je vous remercie d'avoir
extérioriser lourd fardeau que vous
portez en vous au lieu d'avoir partagé
avec moi ce souvenir poignant
aujourd'hui je suis ici sur une terre
qui porte complètement conjointement à
une mémoire ancestrale et cicatrices de
blessure encore béante
je suis ici parmi vous parce que la
première étape de ce pèlerinage
pénitentielle
c'est de renouveler ma demande de pardon
et de vous dire de tous car
que je suis profondément affligé
je demande pardon
pour la manière dont malheureusement de
nombreux chrétiens ont soutenu la
mentalité colonisatrice des puissances
qui ont opprimé et peuples autochtones
je suis affligé
je demande pardon
en particulier pour la manière dont de
nombreux membres de l'église et des
communautés religieuses ont coopéré même
à travers l' indifférence à ses projets
de destruction culturelle et
d'assimilation forcée des gouvernements
de l'époque qui ont abouti au système
des pensionnats pour autochtones
photo rémy gabalda bieber la youtube un
faucheur hingis me dise bureau mais mme
rice
in the
us
open et un open your love again a
dit sorry
sorry
[Applaudissements]
sorry for the ways in which we were a
boy
microsoft
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pratiks com
and for simulation promod
bien que la charité chrétienne et était
présente et qu'il y est eu de nombreux
cas exemplaire de dévouement envers les
enfants
les conséquences générales des
politiques liées aux pensionnats pour
autochtones
ont été
catastrophiques ce que la foi chrétienne
nous dit c'est qu'il s'agissait d'une
erreur
dévastatrice incompatible avec
l'évangile de jésus-christ il est
douloureux de savoir que ce socle solide
de valeur de langue et de culture qui a
donné à vos peuples un authentique sens
d'identité
s'est érodée et que vous continuez à en
subir les conséquences
face à ce mal qui indignent
l'église s'agenouille devant dieu et
implore le pardon des péchés de ses
enfants
je voudrais le répéter avec honte et
clarté je demande humblement pardon pour
le mal commis par de nombreux chrétiens
contre les peuples autochtones
par
des
incapables
le
coach des merengue
my soul
rnb
i'll be back forgiveness ford et yvonne
communication et guess jeans pipeau
chers frères et soeurs
[Applaudissements]
quels ils ont seulement annoncé chers
frères et cherche un vrai bon nombre
d'entre vous et de vos représentants
elles ont affirmé que les excuses ne
sont pas un point final je suis
entièrement d'accord
elle constitue seulement la première
étape le point de départ
j'ai moi aussi conscience que
considérant le passé ce que l'on peut
faire pour demander pardon et réparation
du dommage causé ne sera jamais
suffisant et que considérant l'avenir
rien ne doit être négligé pour
promouvoir une culture capable non
seulement de faire en sorte que de
telles situations ne se reproduisent pas
mais encore que celle ci ne puisse
trouver de terrain propice pour être
dissimulé perpétuer une partie
importante de ce processus consiste à
mener une sérieuse recherche sur la
vérité du passé et à aider les
survivants des pensionnats pour
autochtones à entreprendre des chemins
de guérison pour les traumatismes subis
anglais
mais review et mieux représenté avec
19 de marque iphone ou gris tu as raison
mais d'offrir ce thème de
noël faisait peur
et si tu donnes un verbe et sophie
dahl
no more people tout contre eux et
d'autres provinces sauf si tu jouais
chez from binning
and power of de
strasbourg bitche conduct
investigations
mais sauf
vaisseau
je crie
so i et pelo et le joli trio et j'espère
que les chrétiens et la société de cette
terre
grandiront de leur capacité à accueillir
et à respecter l'identité et
l'expérience des peuples autochtones
j'espère que des moyens concrets seront
trouvées pour les connaître et les
apprécier en apprenant à avancer tous
ensemble
pour ma part je continuerai à encourager
l'engagement de tous les catholiques à
l'égard des peuples autochtones
je les fais à plusieurs reprises et en
divers lieux par des rencontres des
appels et même par une exhortation
apostolique
je sais que tout cela demande du temps
et de la patience ce sont des processus
qui doivent gagner nos coeurs ma
présence ici est l'engagement des
évêques canadiens
témoigne de la volonté d'avancer sur
cette voie
anglais
métro
elle respecte l'identité index fund of
business people
griffonné sur un
bout
de
papier
yousfi king of prostate
testimony
l'espace
c'est ce pèlerinage s'étend sur quelques
jours
et tout sera des lieux distants les uns
des autres
toutefois il ne me permettra pas de
donner suite à de nombreuses invitations
ni de visiter des centres tels que
kamloops winnipeg
diversit en saskatchewan au yukon ou
dans les territoires du nord-ouest
même si ce n'est pas possible
sachez que vous êtes tous et toutes dans
les coeurs dans mes pensées et mes
prières sachez que je connais les
souffrances les traumatismes et les
défis des peuples autochtones dans
toutes les régions de ce pays
mes paroles prononcées tout au long de
ce voyage pénitentielle s'adresse à
toutes les communautés et à tous les
autochtones que j'embrasse de tout coeur
anglais
entre
ivan son fils bernard la mitre accepte
une invitation à
winnipeg éleveurs species in
saskatchewan yukon et au nord ouest à
nos
amis et ennemis peurs nos
experts
discovery ne vivent que mindy mmorpg
aion brice ollivier you with a fait
étape à qui s'élève à la première étape
j'ai voulu faire place à la mémoire
aujourd'hui je suis ici pour me souvenir
du passé pour pleurer avec vous pour
regarder la terre en silence et pour
prier sur les tombes
laissons le silence nous aider tous et
tout intérioriser la douleur le silence
et la prière
face au mal prions le seigneur du bien
et face à la mort crions le dieu de la
vie
le seigneur jésus-christ a fait d'un
tombeau impasse de la l'espérance devant
lequel tous les rêves s'était évanoui et
où il n'était resté que pleurent douleur
et résignation il a fait de ce tombeau
le lieu de la renaissance de la
résurrection d'où est partie une
histoire de vie nouvelle et de
réconciliation universelle
nos efforts ne suffisent pas pour guérir
et réconciliée nous avons besoin de sa
grâce nous avons besoin de la sagesse
douce et forte de l'esprit de la
tendresse du consommateur qu'il comble
les attentes de nos coeurs qu'ils nous
prennent par la main qu'ils nous fassent
marcher ensemble
unique space for mairie
ce n'est
pas
un pays
symons empereur
il nous fait vivre oui prêtre aura
aucune
il ne fait sauf jeff oui près tous deux
gars voix off
alors j'y serai
avec robin van persie
ni ennemis ni
haine
universe ou
la rénovation
winnicott gries
wind that help of wisdom of
art comme le
messie bring to fuck you mean to find
the deep expectations
sauvegarde
tenebras tout 22 gars 20 ans notre jury
alors voilà c'était les mots tant
attendue du pape comment seront celles
accueilli
kelly leur portée on en parlera un peu
plus tard la cérémonie n'est pas tout à
fait terminée puisque on doit entendre
bientôt encore une fois du tambour et
des chants il y aura également
il y aura également une bénédiction
finale de la part d'un aîné qui va prier
le notre père en langue crie
bah
[Applaudissements]
generation sont aussi beaux
date we sing song n
1 sans frais pour les enfants et aussi
pour nos dirigeants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ja
hier
et
eux
m
le
[Applaudissements]
ca
hélas
bien née
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
k
[Applaudissements]
ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça passe et course
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
il
[Musique]
m
non
et puis
je
alors on assiste
après après ces paroles du pape à tous
et sur le vent en famille proche
le paf reçoit on le voit des cadeaux le
vus même
recevoir des mails du chef willie
lui-même survivants du pensionnat
the west et fitch qui avait remis donc
une coiffe de grands chefs
et qui maintenant lui même le pape remet
des cadeaux du vatican aux différentes
personnes qui défilent sur l'estrade
je
il a remis on l'a vu aussi les mocassins
qu'on lui avait donné que la délégation
autochtone qui s'était rendu à rome en
avril lui avait donné et qu'il ramène
aujourd'hui
avec une symbolique de se rappeler d'une
part les enfants morts dans les
pensionnats le drame des pensionnats
mais aussi la symbolique de la marche
ensemble
continuer à avancer vers la
réconciliation
ja pressent qu'il reçoit
les documents anciens ou peut-être pas
alors c'est ça on les chefs lui remettre
des cadeaux c'est ce sont sept chefs en
fait autochtone qui je présume au nom de
chacune de leur communauté ou nation
remettent des cadeaux hop apprend soir
alors je vous demandez peut-être à
chacun d'entre vous je vais commencer
par vous il a belle vous avez entendu je
vous ai vu très ému un moment donné
pendant qu'on écoutait le pape et qu'on
voyait tout ça se dérouler pendant le
discours après aussi votre toute
première réaction à ce discours est ce
qu'il répond à vos attentes
c'est difficile de répondre en tant que
forme des pros nomination je veux
laisser
l'option à tous les survivants
d'accueillir les paroles le discours du
pape de la façon dont il le veut bien
donc je ne peux pas répondre dans des
survivants en mon nom personnel par
contre
j'ai trouvé ça difficile parce que
encore plusieurs fois il a parlé de
mauvais chrétienne de pommes pourries à
l'intérieur de l'église avant de
finalement dire l'église demande pardon
à dieu ils ont un peu élargie mais pour
moi c'était très très
j'étais à peine 10 à peine à peine
mentionné ya aussi tout ce côté de
recherche par contre qu'il mentionnait
il faut aller plus loin et il dit qu'il
a entendu que c'était important de faire
une enquête et pour moi ce que ça veut
dire ça c'est qu'il va faciliter la
recherche des archives autre que
j'espère c'est ce que j'ai entendu
maintenant j'ai aussi entendu cette
femme qui après
office de chant en fait c'est l'hymne
national que le chanteur lancry je pense
que c'était planifié et c'était
extrêmement émouvant de voir ça et ça
représentait justement d'autres
survivants qui je pense ne veut rien
savoir faire les excuses du pape que
c'est du trop peu trop tard voilà on va
écouter les grilles remercie s'appelle
aurait coûté brièvement la
caisse
ainsi
que des
rencontres et le 5 mai il y a les aînés
qui son génie pour remettre des présents
au saint père donc pour la sécurité de
chacun je vous prie de respecter l'ordre
nos anciens nous et nice mais survivants
présents ils sont désireux de remettre
leurs présents au saint père
le plus
oui matin à praia monde et praia au ska
soul aux
conseils aux femmes la boîte est une
autre paire métaux verre qui est
soucieux que ton nom soit sanctifié que
ton règne vienne que ta volonté soit
faite sur la terre comme au ciel
donne nous
aujourd'hui notre teint de ce jour
pardonne nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés et ne nous laisse pas entrer en
tentation mais délivre nous du mal des
lobbys williwoo seigneur soit avec vous
bénis par le seigneur
les élèves hors de l'eau
nous venons secours au nom du seigneur
mes remarques des causes les yeux
puis saison dieu tout du sol et vous
bénir au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit
[Applaudissements]
m
internet
je
alors à l'est les rebelles parce que je
vous disais en regardant le pape qui
viennent passer quelques quelques
minutes de boot même à accueillir
ces signes de reconnaissance et ces
échanges de cadeaux ces accolades ses
embrassades parce qu'elle défunt qui ont
voulu prendre dans leurs bras
et qui se retrouve maintenant à devoir
s'asseoir vous disais que son médecin
lui recommandait pas trop marché en
15-16 ça a été envoyée aussi à travers
le réseau de l'organisme des
organisateurs oui du cauvel pivot à
faire le monsieur fait keynes pas besoin
de plus on comprend pourquoi on voit
bien qu'il ya énormément de difficultés
à se déplacer mais on est mal yat il me
bat je regarde sa fille maisie mais où
sommes-nous terre on est habitué de voir
des images soignées
koné dans le marbre de l'italie même
placé pierre ont terminé de voir des
images qui sont
contrôlés en fait certainement contrôler
absolument seymour et chercher et là
c'est parce qu'ils contrôlaient pas cool
ce qui me fait dire ça cette femme qui
chante le ô canada à sa manière contre
arrive de ma pole texte mais je sentais
qu'elle est la dame une tonne d'émotion
on contrôle les choses habituellement la
saint pierre puis même à l'intérieur de
la basilique où dans la salle climatisée
nouveau procès s'impose mais en même
temps ça nous donne un sentiment de
quelque chose de peut-être plus
authentique je m'entraîne dit que tout
le monde devrait se réjouir de ses
excuses mais j'ai eu le sentiment qu'il
était en territoire authentique et qui
avait quelque chose d'authentiqué de la
classe dont la spontanéité du contrôle
et sont conscients du courrier de
spontané il est capable de se
débarrasser de son texte mais pas là je
sais pas encore une fois il a dit le mot
pardon hein j'ai bien compté trois fois
toi peut-être 4 puis enfin il finit par
décoller les étages nous c'est là
j'avais pas tendu à jarry entendu sur
mon sort et est ce que c est ce que ça
va jusqu'à dire nous l'église avons
commis ce sinon je vois pas ce qu'il dit
quand il demande pardon ils le demandent
toujours au nom de nombreux chrétiens
qui eux
on est adoptée la colonisation et la
civilisation des autochtones les
nombreux chrétiens comme commis des abus
mais c'est jamais au nom de l'église non
mais il prend c'est comme si il
s'appropriait pas la responsabilité
mépris s'approprie cependant la suite
des choses pas la faute mais quelque
chose d'autre est-ce que ce soit
suffisant mais vous avez vu certains des
chefs autochtones étaient willie willie
les touches à le premier il semblait
tout à fait satisfait des excuses
inattendues cela puisqu'il hier dans
l'émotion on a eu une bonne dose d
nationale à des gens qui sont satisfaits
parce que ça va satisfaire tout le monde
du ballon
marie-eve j'aimerais vous entendre comme
psychiatre sur sur justement la demande
de pardon parce que à rome et s'est
excusé la commune et des excuses mais
c'était demande de pardon il ya une
différence oui il ya des nuances et à
dire que présenter des excuses on
présente les excuses mais ce n'est pas
un terme qui engage quelque chose de
relationnel quand on est dans une
demande de pardon on demande alors
quelque chose on lui demande
de nous de nous pardonner pour cette
donc on est dans quelque chose de
rationnel entre
partis interpelle on est dans une
relation absolument et j'ai beaucoup
aussi qu'ils aiment et qui mentionne ce
n'est bien sûr ses excuses de sa demande
de pardon qu'une première étape et il y
auriez qui sera jamais suffisant ce je
trouvais ça intéressant de le nommer
parce que c'est vrai et j'ai trouvé très
intéressant qui est des réactions
différentes et hétérogène dans la salle
ça c'est qu'effectivement des chefs qui
ont semblé satisfaits qui sont allés le
voir qui était dans un esprit de gérer
de communion avec eux il ya eu cette
expression de grande détresse de grande
colère dans cette femme qui chante et
qui est aussi une réaction qui va y
avoir dans les communautés donc cette
hétérogénéité je trouvais qu'elle était
saine s'est elle sans qu'elle soit
représentée par ce que ça représente et
je trouvais que la bonne façon de les
réduire et agir c'est avec beaucoup
d'humilité parce que cette colère le et
les gens qui seront pas satisfait de ça
c'est tout à fait lit j'aime leur
réaction aussi gare de pau de réaction
plus légitime que d'autres compte tenu
de l'ampleur de l'horreur dont on parle
là je vous propose d'aller chercher une
autre réaction celle de survivants celle
du chef du conseil des innus
d'ekuanitshit sur la côte-nord au québec
jean charles piétacho cui mais super
tâche au
cui alors dites nous votre réaction
comment vous avez écouté ce que le pas
bien dire quelle est votre réaction
écoutez j'ai écouté
tout
un loisir le secours y avait eu ramos
qui m'ont interpellé lui aussi mais dans
un premier temps j'ai besoin de temps
pour remercier toutes nos nombreuses
personnes qui ont organisé
le voyage jusqu'à 4 à 5 dans la tanière
et les autres et surtout reconnaître
le travail en commun des vos mains de
notre chef régional du syndicat et de
lâches
mendy goal dimassi qui était présente
entendu le message que le pape allait
venir au canada et
six armes je regarde ça de façon
froide si on peut dire ça comme ça l'a
raconté les mots si je joue mon mac
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à retrouver que ceux comme
moi je pensais en sait que le pape est
venu canada essentiellement pour
s'excuser auprès des ex pensionnaires
banlieue des phrases et quand on dit je
ne demande pardon à magna est connue
dont on a été traités par des chrétiens
cet appel
oui celui principes et à l'impasse du
débat est
bien présent on parle par dans le
malheur humain comme il fallait nombreux
chrétiens bras comme il faut leur
bulletin de d'écouter puis de morceaux
et la citation de limousin venu devant
du
japon dû
me tromper lomé mais dans tous leurs
garçons moi je ne
reconnais pas je ne vois pas ce que moi
je voulais aux gens tant pour ce que je
voulais en parler c'est vraiment qu'on
dise
demande pardon présente mes excuses au
nom de l'église catholique on en est
encore une fois à une banalisation
de notre situation nous les ex
pensionnaires et
je regardais aussi la met dans le mille
notes parce que moi je le prends
beaucoup de notre dame et les
interventions et
attend pour moi ça c'est mon mon point
personnel ça c'est à chaque journée ex
pensionnaires et a subi tous les
services à tous les niveaux et qui
aujourd'hui et j'ai eu dans une
communauté depuis plus de 30 ans c'est
moi j'ai été
enlevé avec nous mais il faille
dans les années 50 tours et 60 et 360
tour et
un coup de main je sais de comparable de
saisie mais c'est sur le disque ou comme
tel dans sa totalité la
prendre le tas mais pendant prenons le
temps mais ça fait des années que nous
nous attendons et on va devoir
attends je peux combien d'années je sais
pas lassé de voir comment seront les
actions après qu'est ce qu'on fait là et
aujourd'hui
ce que j'espère quand il quand on allie
j'espère que record comores à québec
les excuses pour ce qu'ils sont des
places il ya de nombreux ex pensionnaire
avec les ennemis qui se rendent à
sainte-anne et ne sais pas ce que sera
dissous il moi je vais quand même parce
qu'on nous pardonne leur conciliation
mais est ce qu'on adule est ce que des
gens sont vendus mois pour le moment me
suis rendu là pour
entendre les excuses terre qui combiné
avec l'interrogation vois ça en vrai
c'est mon bonbon est là c'est parce que
moi j'ai beaucoup de douleur aussi un
comme la plupart déjà d'avoir été un
mais deux nous famille d'un des camions
est amené dans un pensionnat à
l'extérieur par n'a plus de 5,1 10,1
pour certainement de l'ex et
abusé sexuellement aussi on comprenait
pas moi j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi je suis parti de chez eux de
chez moi donc j'étais très heureux avec
mes grands parents qui m'ont gardé ma
naissance et puis moi j'essaie de dire
souvent ou 20 imaginez imaginez vous que
vous êtes en train de jouer des tours 1
2 5 6 7 1 pour jouer et on est à vauban
est mauvais dans un camion et vous amène
à l'aréoport
american pie
des avions et je vois ma g à chrysler
pour amorcer
les bleus et on m'a collé pour que moi
je puisse être
mais cette actrice était le black
traitait de l'accord mais elle des
souvenirs
humains sonore très douloureux il m'est
très heureux parce qu'on a subies je
peux avoir un discours de victimisation
ici ce soir tout le monde l'a entendu
mais angers personnes un corps a compris
succès au cesa a pris les événements de
gamme luxe qui continue et qu'elle
allait cesser ses seins
ce qui ne sommes jamais revenu sur jez
gendarmes venus là le ton monte non on
est comme on va dire chanceux d'être
tombé chez nous mais d'entendre
aujourd'hui et avait des jeunes enfin du
jeu n'ont pas de quatre cinq six
semaines et ont été enlevées dans leur
famille et je m'excuse
de ce que j'ai entendu
du président répondra conférant des
oreilles du canada quand ils en
voulaient du traité ont voulu qu'ils
sortent de leur misère est esquissée ont
étudié le même j'avais le famine c'est
une autre vie c'était notre culture
s'était ainsi que nous activités
personnelles par dès l'automne je pense
aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui fait que dans mon cas
d'amont lamoura je vais continuer oui
c'est une étape chez cet enfant et je le
prends comme ça pour moment et de mère
tchèque après après le bateau du support
ou être vous irez à québec monsieur
piétacho mais je comprends donc vous
espériez plus vous attendez
d'aujourd'hui que le pape dise davantage
disent autre chose ça aurait été un plus
grands jalons la dent dans la guérison
et la réconciliation
on dirait c'est luce quelques chrétiens
qui ont fait le même donc on a suivi et
ses 5 îles fait interpeller a dit que le
simple
demande par dans la peau de l'église
catholique
c'est sur mon si je regarde quand il dit
l'église s'agenouille devant dieu oui
mais si c'est un toit
le temps aussi comme très sûres déjà je
veux me rendre à québec à la carabine 3
commente pas la fête
merci pète à chaud merci beaucoup pour
votre témoignage votre réaction à chaud
justement remercie jamais revoir
allons maintenant écoutez la réaction de
thérèse [ __ ] qui elle aussi une
survivante elle du pensionnat de
pointe-bleue originaire de la communauté
de manawan dont elle dirige maintenant
les services et projets communautaires
c'est une attikameks originaire de
wemotaci madani cui cui pour jour quinn
oui
oui ok
pour ce qui est de mes attentes je
n'avais pas moi dès lors si je suivais
ça un peu de loin parce que moi pour ce
qui est des institutions comme l'église
catholique où les gouvernements moi j'en
ai j'ai le coeur gros lot par rapport à
tout ce qu'on a subi là donc moi j'avais
pas réellement d'atteinte par contre
j'ai complété émules de voir le pape
chez les autochtones comme ça puis moi
je remercie toutes les personnes qui ont
initié depuis des années l'eau pour
faire la lumière sur ce qui s'est passé
lors d'un ce pensionnat long c'était un
travail de longue haleine il se sent
comme
jamais ils n'ont jamais abandonné dans
le fond pour faire
connaître la vérité vie pour en arriver
au sila à ce que a sollicité la visite
du pape pie xi et puis finalement par
mains à maintes reprises finalement le
pape a accepté de venir je remercie tous
ceux qui ont travaillé pour que ces
événements-là et lieu présentement parce
que c'est vrai qu'on ne l'aurait cru
comme ex pensionnaires c'est ça a été
très très lourd pendant des années là à
ne pas savoir exactement qu'est ce qui
m'est arrivé ne vais essayer de faire la
lumière sur sont encore aujourd'hui
prime pour moi la mise attente d'un
enfant c'est aussi j'aimerais voir de
façon concrète comment on va faire pour
faire en sorte que nos jeunes
aujourd'hui dans nos communautés qui
sont en pleine détresse nos jeunes nos
enfants nos petits enfants
c'est à eux que je pense que je pense
aussi à l'opération on a arraché des
enfants c'est toute cette perturbation
inter
générationnelle
vraiment on va faire pour redonner tout
son sens à la vie l'eau informe les six
nations et madame unique et vous vous
incarnez d'une certaine façon un exemple
malheureusement parfait de cette
souffrance intergénérationnel puisque
vos parents ont souffert de vous voir
partir pour le pensionnat vous avez
souffert au pensionnat de toutes sortes
de sévices dont un viol aux mains d'un
prêtre et vos enfants ont souffert de
cette souffrance que vous avez rapporté
du pensionnat n'est ce pas
exactement il la souffrance est toujours
présente
parce que tout ce qu'on a subi dans le
fond que plusieurs d'autres insulines
longtemps on le portait son nom n'étant
pas capable de de souvenirs aujourd'hui
c'est sûr qu'à des ressources qui se met
en place ne s'est pas encore assez moi
je vois la détresse la jolie jeune fille
on se demande qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
ça on sait il ya une chose qui m'a que
je retiens d'aujourd'hui la coiffe
économies sur la tête du pape il l'a
enlevé presque aussitôt ça s'annonçait
tout quoi et en plus de la 3g ressources
et des mocassins déjà redonné les staffs
parce qu'on fait pas les choses à moitié
quand on veut réparer puis quand on veut
réellement la réconciliation à trois
mois sa marque jeune je comprends que le
parc soit en tant que personne peut être
d'une sincérité
mais c'est aux comores celui qui a parlé
avant c'est comme si c'était juste
quelques personnes de l'église qui ont
comme ça alors que l'église comme
institution est
responsable de gestes d'oppression qu'on
aurait vite parce qu'on nous a enlevé la
pratique des rituels des cérémonies
c'est ça qui faisait notre force c'est
là dessus qu'ils reposent en hauteur le
sens large président lesaint sacré elle
était là dedans puis c'est tout ça qu'on
nous a retiré pour nous insulter nous
endoctriner dans la religion catholique
mais les exemples connus des figures qui
est exposé d'être des figures
maternelles paternel cape tawny théo
passionnant ben si ceux là mêmes qui
nous ont abusé alors je comprends madame
nique et que vous êtes déçu finalement
de ce que vous avez vu et entendu même
si vous restez que vous respectez la
figure l'homme derrière le pape mais
vous serez à québec quand même vous y
allez pourquoi
moi je bois québec pas pour ali à
saint-andré pour aller voir ce niveau là
parce que j'ai un fils qui est là
justement qui est un vivier vit des
difficultés vis et hop mon fils que je
vais suivre l'actualité mais je dirais
quand même que pour moi c'est un temps
que c'est quand même un endroit où
j'aime ali parce que mes parents nos
parents et merle et l'appui comme lieu
de rassemblement entre les premières
nations pour moi c'est un endroit
important d'autant plus que quand on
parle de cinq ans c'est la grandeur de
jc mais moi je dis que quelque chose de
spécial à cet endroit un peu trop
longtemps après la le décès de ma grand
mère et c'est là que j'ai réalisé pour
la première fois je me sentais bien dans
une église j'avais 25 ans parce qu'avant
pour moi quand je n'entrais dans une
église
c'était la peur parce que la manière que
nous a inculqué la religion catholique
c'est en nous faisant peur d'eux si on
fait quelque chose de travers dernière
dire qu'il me regarde dans qui vont nous
punir donc pour moi je suis resté très
longtemps avec cet esprit là parce que
j'avais même un juge quand je disais au
début il m'est arrivé des choses ici des
années après que j'ai pu faire la
lumière sur tout ce que j'ai pu subir
comme l'endoctrinement puis tout à
l'heure le lavage de cerveau dans le
fond il a fallu des années pour me des
conditio nez de tout ça pour pouvoir
aujourd'hui je suis fier des fêtes qu'un
mec que moi je marche avec mes
traditions les cérémonies est tout pour
moi c'est ce qui compterait plus
technique et merci beaucoup
coup d'avoir accepté de témoigner pour
nous aujourd'hui de revenir là dessus
merci beaucoup merci bien au revoir
vous vous rappelez peut-être avant la
cérémonie où il dit n'être paul sur
place on voit ce que chase avait
recueilli le témoignage les attentes de
monsieur andré carrier vous vous
rappelez il était croyant il était plein
d'espoir à l'égard de ce que le pape
allait dire eh bien voici sa réaction
après un discours du pape
père m'en sépare homme a touché mon
coeur qui a parlé de la doller a parlé
de la partie en a pas de notre culture
on a peu de navx a pas de respect chez
nous comme métis il ya parlé de tout
cette chose qui se met vraiment tout mon
coeur parce que c'est l'occasion de
réconciliation c'est l'occasion de
pardonner se pardonner pour les dollars
puis l'église est demandée pour qu'on le
pardon pour la les tous les habits qu'on
a suffi souffert risque d'après la les
mains des religieux et des prêts à la
pour moi c'est une étape de une étape
très brillant de la future parce que on
va recevoir que il reconnaît
les choses mauvaises et l'on s'est passé
et il serait l'occasion pour se rétablir
et convaincre avec le respect de la
famille pendant une des excuses dans les
ententes
certaines personnes
oui on attendu
de la part de tous les autochtones ici
au canada qu'on est super
pour moi c'est très bien parce que c'est
ici de dire les touts les communautés
malheureusement le problème c'est
c'était à travers le canada au complet
c'est pas juste un endroit c'était
s'était établi à travers le canada alors
son excuse pour moi assène bonnes bonnes
fondations pour la peau notre futur vous
à l'église est ce que vous êtes
satisfait par rapport à ce que vous avez
entendu aujourd'hui oui je suis
satisfait je suis heureux de le quitter
parce que je reconnais que j'ai
confiance avec avec le pape de qu'ils
soient très sincère avec ses paroles
qu'est-ce qui nous a traversé l'esprit
alors que vous c'est coutier le pape a
prononcé ces paroles j'ai un flic
gpra six mois
j'étais amis m'ont parlé de ses traits
envoyée aux mesures à travers tous ces
témoignages ces réactions le l'intensité
de
ressenti de ce que ces gens ont vécu et
de ce que ça réveille tout ça isabelle
picard on a vu aussi la déception là à
travers les témoignages 2 sur 3 des
témoignages qu'on a des réactions qu'on
a entendu et j'ajouterais la vôtre ou si
votre déception oui je suis très
contente d'avoir entendu deux survivants
qui ont pris la parole parce que je le
disais un peu à part feutrée mais en
fait
le discours du pape a touché mon coeur
comme j'aurais espéré qu'il le touche et
je me dis si elle peut toucher le mien
je ne sais pas pour les pour les les
survivants bien sûr c'est à chaque
survivant d'accueillir ce discours-là de
la façon dont il veut le faire
c'est pas à moi à leur dire quoi penser
ou quoi
quoi faire en lien avec ça mais monsieur
péter cho et madame nick wey optique oui
nico et voilà ont eu des réactions
que je reconnais des réactions
auxquelles je m'attendais parce que on
reste un peu de glace je dirais qu'il ya
pas été capable de toucher
la fibre que j'aurais aimé qu'ils
puissent toucher évidemment ils sont dix
courtes et très place et c'était très
niche et évidemment on l'entendait
peut-être qu'un peu plus de spontanéité
aurait eu un effet autres mais
effectivement j'ai été un peu 10
marie-eve concernant je me disais en
écoutant les réactions que sans doute
les plus croyants ont voulu voir dans ce
discours du pape des excuses et les
moins croyants jeu se passe on peut
l'interpréter ou comprendre comme ça ça
devait beaucoup dépendre je pense des ex
des attentes des gens thomas n'avait pas
non plus les mêmes attentes je pense que
certains vont donner plus d'importance
au fait qu'ils se soient présentés qui
étaient là les mots pour eux vont être
peut-être plus secondaires pour d'autres
les mots étaient importants et je suis
d'accord je comprends tout à fait la
réaction des gens moi j'ai trouvé qu'il
manquait de prise de responsabilités
systémiques c'est-à-dire de deux pauvres
placer la responsable est de la faute
sur certains chrétiens nous sommes et de
vraiment nommé l'inscription et la
complicité système est très clair
organiser de l'église dans ce génocide
culturel et aussi quand il parlait de
début le mentionner abus physiques et
verbaux pour moi c'est vraiment une
tache aveugle une grosse mission de ne
pas avoir nommé les abus sexuels parce
que c'était d'une telle ampleur c'est
tellement important comme dans dans les
traumatismes qu'ils ont eu lieu là est
vraiment un objectif unification des
enfants pour ça et je trouve que
commission l'église beaucoup de
difficultés à parler ouvertement avec
transparence de ces difficultés de
gestion de la sexualité à l'intérieur de
la communauté d'aidé de ce que ça peut
engendrer et sa part avancé d'enfants on
le voit un peu aujourd'hui et en dépit
de tous les antécédents donc c'est là où
des excuses ou dix demandes de pardon
les mots sont importants il y aurait
plus je pense être plus spontané plus
authentique plus
touchant mais il ya aussi qu'est-ce
qu'on annonce comme action est ce
qu'elle aurait pu nommer clairement
qu'ils allaient donner accès aux
archives à ce qu'ils peuvent parler à
l'intérieur de l'église qui font un
exercice d'analysé leurs problèmes de
gestion de la sexualité de contrôle de
soja mais on ne peut en tout cas à ma
connaissance on eu le discours de
l'église on reconnaît qu'on a
on a un problème de contrôle de gestion
de la sexualité qui ont donné lieu à
beaucoup d'abus notamment auprès des
autochtones on up on n'entend jamais
allé je vais terminer avec vous ce tour
de table dans le fond si l'image de
l'église céser boncelles avait un rôle
pas tenir aujourd'hui à jouer auprès de
ces autochtones là mais si son image
aussi l'image de l'église catholique
qu'il représente l'institution comment
il s'en est tiré aujourd'hui avons très
bien fait rien moi je passais pour le
jovialiste du groupe là mais je pense
que je m'attendais pas autant
c'est clair il ya quelqu'un qui me
faisait il ya part condamné l'église
c'est là y'a pas dit nous avons produit
nous soyons ses positions que celles de
tout ce n'est pas possible s'excluent
pas et alors ça c'est absents prendre le
tailleur survivants qu'ils aient prendre
l'état mais ça fait déjà pas mal
longtemps à loos tout ça ce sont des
failles mais je lis jamais entendu
parler autant de pardon de les mots
qu'il a utilisé je pensais de plus loin
que j'ai vu un pape alé dans un truc
pareil et en même temps je me dis comme
je dis je pensais pour le jovialiste du
groupe en même temps je me dis à ce
qu'on mesure le chemin qui a été
parcouru
la semaine dernière je parlais avec
quelqu'un de l'église unie que vous
aimez vous souvenez vous à ce que vous
qui aurait cru qu'on aurait aujourd'hui
le pape le la à dire ce qui est dit là
jamais un noyau 5 10 15 ans j'aurais pas
que ça je pensais que c'était terminé
c'était une histoire que l'elysée est
l'ennemi et advitam eternam pénètre dans
les livres d'histoire agents mais alors
le piège c'est celui-là c'est à dire que
s'il faut qu ils déçoivent
alors là je pense qu'il ya un livre je
donne dans le cas de beaucoup de gens a
provoqué quelque chose de rond point
qui l'ont applaudi le 3 froid des
cétacés un peu par ce cri pour une skoda
hector on va on va on va falloir
comprendre un peu mieux s'il a fait le
plein de foule là parce que ça semblait
pas aussi plein que ça vont s'attendre à
cette adresse mail personnes sur les
chaussées oui c'est simca type mais on
verra ce qu on est un peu plus tard
pierre aussi le fait que bon il s'en va
on est encore discours
il s'en va à québec qui va faire des
prières alors peut-être que il va
adapter aller plus loin compte tenu de
la déception qu'on a aujourd'hui huit
ans et dont on connaît limitée a vu mon
travail alors que l'autre des gens qui
parlent le critt des gens qui parlent de
lui par l'espanyol dans une interprète
entre les deux de l'anglais qui sema la
salle l'émotion passe pas facilement
s'être chef d'état mais surtout si le
chef du lys catholique alors c'est le
discours y est écrit il est écrit leur
est peaufinée peaufiner celui
d'aujourd'hui vit on n'est pas tout à
fait dans l'avion qui le ramène avant
mouiller dans son discours puis je veux
parler de nous et on n'est pas lol
marie-eve coton alain crevier isabelle
picard merci infiniment tous les trois
d'avoir partagé avec nous ce moment
qu'on peut qualifier d'historique après
tout on aura l'occasion de s'en reparler
on est pas toutes les données ont il ya
beaucoup d'inconnues encore concernant
justement les gens qui se trouvaient sur
place il y aura d'autres réactions tout
au long de la journée moi en tout cas je
vous dis au revoir pour l'instant que je
vous retrouve vous donne rendez vous ce
soir 18h30 heure de l'est le pape sera
dans une église paroissiale denton à ce
soir sans rendez vous merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah ah
et
[Musique]
la paix
et à
à